November 26 2014 a plot of federal land
in the midwestern United States appears
to be completely uninhabited but to
those in the know this is actually the
location of biological research area 12.
a large SCP Foundation facility that
houses and experiments on live
biological entities and hazardous tissue
samples already it was proving to be a
challenging day for the Personnel
stationed at area 12. due to what seemed
like a freak technical glitch they were
dealing with a system failure and a
large-scale containment breach the
deadly bladed pedals of scp-143 were
drifting through the air the acidic
scp-153 roundworms were breeding
scp-811 was running wild and a number of
amnesia-inducing scp-939 creatures had
escaped their pen
in short it was a total disaster
complete paranormal pandemonium and
things were about to get so much worse
as the sounds of wearing helicopter
blades and the rumbling engines of heavy
military vehicles approached the
embattled staff were relieved that
mobile task force reinforcements were
arriving so quickly after all area 12
was relatively isolated and they'd only
just put in a call for help on-site
security staff were being overwhelmed in
the chaos of the Containment Breach and
they needed the big guns if they wanted
to get things under control before it
was too late what they didn't know as
the vehicles surrounded their facilities
is that it was already far too late for
most of them soon heavily armed troops
and protective tactical gear were
storming the facility as they entered
terrified staff members ran towards them
for protection and then stopped in their
tracks these soldiers didn't bear the
Insignia of the SCP Foundation or any
known mobile task force nor did they
bear the symbols of the global occult
Coalition this was something different
together some of the foundation
Personnel began to beg for assistance
anyway seeing it as in any port in the
storm situation they realized too late
that this group wasn't here to save them
and met their end in a hail of bullets
from the soldiers assault rifles when
the actual mobile task force finally did
arrive they witnessed a horrifying sight
most of the on-site Foundation Personnel
had been shot dead and there were no
trace of the culprits even worse several
of the scp-939 creatures were missing
these are the predatory pack hunting
creatures that produce some nestic
chemicals to lure and disorient their
prey these anomalies are dangerous
enough on their own but in the hands of
someone who really knew how to use them
these living amnestic factories could
pose an extremely serious threat the
mobile task force members knew what they
were dealing with here only one group
would have the nerve to perform a high
casualty Heist on an SCP Foundation
facility during a containment breach the
chaos Insurgency the mobile task force
reported the incident back to command
and already knew what their next mission
would be track down the Insurgency
Splinter Cell and get the 939s back this
Mission would have the absolute highest
stakes and if they weren't successful
there was no limit to the damage the
chaos Insurgency could do with a
creature as dangerous as scp-939 under
their control but who exactly are the
chaos Insurgency what do they want and
why are they stealing anomalies the
chaos Insurgency is one of the most
mysterious and clandestine of the groups
that fight against the SCP Foundation
they are different from the global
occult Coalition the United Nations
offshoot created after the seventh
occult War whose mission is to destroy
rather than try to contain anomalies the
Serpent's hand is on the opposite end of
the spectrum this group strives for the
normalization of the anomalous and the
destruction of the webs of secrecy that
keep the anomalous and consensus reality
separate both the GOC and the Serpent's
hand have clear ideals and mission
statements but the chaos Insurgency is
less forthcoming about their beliefs and
convictions
something we know for sure about the
chaos Insurgency though is that they
view anomalies as tools to be utilized
rather than unpredictable elements to be
contained studied or neutralized to this
end they do whatever it takes to obtain
more anomalies of their own whether it's
ruthlessly seeking out anomalies in the
wild or taking them from the foundation
with coordinated strikes during moments
of weakness though they lack the support
and resources of organizations like the
foundation and the GOC the chaos
Insurgency more than makes up for it in
Devotion to their cause their
unpredictability and most of all their
willingness to use violence it's
difficult to separate the facts from the
rumors when it comes to the chaos
Insurgency some believe that to
compensate for their rejection by the
United Nations as an official group
dealing with anomalous incidents they
instead receive support from certain
dictatorships in the developing World
funded by the blood Money of various
Warlords they carry out their research
on political prisoners and captured
refugees is provided by their murderous
allies they're also believed to
illegally deal both weapons and
intelligence helping the dictators who
fund them remain in power and subjugate
their own people
the foundation has been able to gather
some Intel about the chaos insurgency's
organizational structure which looks
like a strange mirror of their own it's
led by the mysterious Delta command
headed by a figure known only as the
engineer gamma class Personnel execute
the orders of Delta command using the
Lesser beta class personnel as field
operators and finally there is Alpha
class they're typically forced into
conscription from the states occupied by
the Insurgency and serve as Canon fodder
for the group as they track down as many
anomalies as they can and the Insurgency
is believed to possess a number of
powerful anomalies already these include
the Bell ventropy an object that can
cause a variety of destructive effects
depending on where it is struck and the
staff of Hermes
an anomalous object capable of warping
the physical and chemical properties of
any matter it touches
the chaos Insurgency is only growing
more powerful as they continue their
pursuit of money and power with a legion
of militarized anomalies
their goal total world domination other
accounts are a little more charitable to
the beliefs and causes of the chaos
Insurgency they've been described as a
rebellion against the ruthless early
days of the SCP Foundation when they had
a more violent take no prisoner's
attitude this rumor has likely been
disseminated by the chaos Insurgency
themselves though as it paints them in
the most positive and righteous life in
reality the truth as is often the case
is somewhere in the middle danger often
comes from within and the chaos
Insurgency is no exception one constant
in all interpretations of the origin of
the chaos Insurgency is that its members
are rogue elements of the SCP Foundation
and it's commonly believed that they
have countless moles still deep in the
organization today
however one well-kept secret among the
upper echelons of the foundation is that
the creation of the chaos Insurgency is
a lot less unknown than they'd like you
to think yes danger really does often
come from within when researching the
origins of the chaos Insurgency you'll
likely see two dates pop up again and
again
1924 and 1948 according to the official
line from the SCP Foundation 1924 was
the date of the chaos insurgency's
defection in 1948 marked the first
series of violent raids that the chaos
Insurgency LED against the foundation
but these are only half truths while
both dates are indeed significant in the
story of the chaos Insurgency it's for
entirely different reasons 1924 was the
date when the chaos Insurgency known at
the time simply as the Insurgency was
created by the o5 council why would the
SCP foundation's commanding Authority
knowingly create one of the foundation
enemies well you have to understand that
at the time the Insurgency served a very
different purpose they were intended to
be a Black Ops group for the o5 council
capable of doing their dirty work off
the books and out of sight of the rest
of the foundation especially its Ethics
Committee which is often in conflict
with o5 command their members were
recruited from mobile task force alpha 1
also known as the red right hand a
highly secretive MTF in the pocket of
the o5 for 24 years they did the o5
sturdy work while shielding the
foundation's international reputation
from any potential Fallout they were
faithful soldiers until they found
themselves a new master
the engine a mysterious anomalous object
that began to invade and infect the
minds of the Insurgency the group's
human leader the previously mentioned
engineer is merely a puppet of the
engine its human mouthpiece while the
full extent of the engine's plans
remains mysterious to even members of
the chaos Insurgency the engine has been
passing down orders ever since in 1948
the Insurgency fully defected becoming
the chaos Insurgency and they've been a
problem for the SCP Foundation ever
since from raids to assassinations to
threats of damaging the illusion of
consensus reality with their Reckless
Behavior and now thanks to their
acquisition of scp-939 they could get
started on amnestics production too
thankfully for the foundation they had
prepared for 939s getting out into the
world and all the creatures housed at
area 12 had been implanted with
subdermal trackers
several mobile task forces were
immediately dispatched to home in on the
signal take out the insurgents and
secure the 939s once more they track the
signal to a warehouse in the Badlands of
New Mexico where task force members
stormed in and began a tense firefight
with the chaos insurgents all gamma and
beta class of course the Delta classes
just like o5s are notoriously slippery
they emerge like tactical ghosts from
behind boxes and exposed pipes advancing
and firing with no regard for their own
lives and safety slaves to the engine
it wasn't like paddling your
run-of-the-mill cultists these were
highly organized and dangerous
combatants with training right out of
the foundation's mobile task force
Playbook several Foundation soldiers
were lost in the crossfire But
ultimately they won the day subduing the
chaos Insurgency forces and capturing
the stolen nine through nines once more
several of the insurgents that had been
fatally wounded in battle were found to
be area 12 Personnel double agents for
the Insurgency many of them died with
smiles on their faces knowing they were
defying the foundation to their last
breath there was no way of knowing just
how many of these secretive chaos
insurgents were undercover deep in the
fabric of the foundation's global
apparatus a nearby Insurgent slowly
dying from several gunshot wounds gave a
Wheezy laugh
as the task force operators approached
he ranted that the foundation's
obsession with order lies and secrecy is
the real disease that chaos and entropy
is the fate of all things and that to
use the anomalies they find for their
own gain is simply common sense
in the world the chaos Insurgency would
someday create human beings would be the
true Masters of the Universe not just
the perpetrators of the Twisted lie we
call normality he succumbed to his
injuries shortly after and the task
forces refocused their efforts on
getting the 939 safely back to area 12.
what these chaos Insurgency troops
really believe is an open question after
all the power that dictates them the
anomalous engine is a Consciousness
Beyond Humanity even the engineer
doesn't know the true scope of their
Master's grand plan
the rest of us are lucky and the chaos
Insurgency never reaches their
mysterious goals
then neither will we Abel wandered
through the Sands a lone Warrior
dragging a Long Dark Sword behind him
his black cloak flowing in the gentle
breeze the sword was thirsty it had been
too long since it tasted blood what had
it been a day since he cut down 10 men
in a Tavern without breaking a sweat
they bled and screamed like pigs as he
diced them into bloody chunks he
couldn't remember their faces they
hadn't earned that very few combatants
had been remarkable enough to Warrant
committing to memory it was all just
more dead flesh he took a sip from his
canteen inside did this world hold no
more challenges what a boring eternity
was laying out before him his burden as
The Greatest Warrior of all time weighed
on him heavier than the chain it was old
and Rusty levered over his shoulder and
grasped in one bloody hand about 15 feet
behind him the chain was connected to a
dark stone sarcophagus that was as much
a part of him as his eyes skin or heart
if ever he was slain in the Glorious
heat of battle he'd rise out of it ready
to fight and kill another day all
because of the actions of his worthless
good for nothing brother he booked up
when he heard the rush of footsteps and
the clanking of armor Warriors or
whatever pass for them around here about
20 of them circled all around him yes oh
yes his grip tightened around his sword
one of the Warriors called out something
about him being under arrest by order of
the king for murders Beyond counting
Abel couldn't help but yawn words words
words why even bother her he dropped the
chain and in one fluid motion he threw
his sword in a fraction of a second it
pierced the armor of the chattering man
spearing him through his formerly
Beating Heart the scream died in his
throat he fell to his knee days then
collapsed entirely the other soldiers
sent to kill or apprehend him turned to
their Fallen leader in gasp it was that
little gasp that moment of distraction
that sealed their Fates Abel's face
cracked into a whisper of a grin as he
drew two long daggers from the darkness
of his coat he'd at least try to have
fun with this before the others could
even get over their Leader's sudden
death Abel had vaulted forward and begun
his delicate dance of Slaughter every
swing found its way through armor and
into skin he sliced throats cleaved off
heads parried blows and pierced Hearts
there was barely a single scream Abel
killed too quick for screams in what
would seem like the blink of an eye for
some the soldiers around Abel fell most
dead the rest dying some looked up to
him in their dying moments in terrified
awe of the efficacy of their killer in
their dying moments they knew that they
never had a chance they might might as
well have me facing the glistening
Scythe of death himself on the
battlefield Abel on the other hand
rolled his eyes inside another pathetic
waste of time he sensed movement in the
corner of his eye one of the wounded
soldiers was limping to his feet trying
to use the sword to lever himself off of
the ground with a flick of each wrist
Abel tossed his knives into the man
killing him instantly it really was that
easy your attempt to kill me does not
offend me he said to whoever was still
able to hear what offends me is that
they would send so few and that those
few would be such pitiful excuses for
soldiers this wasn't a battle it was a
mercy killing he was ready to turn
around grab the chain and carry on
walking when he felt a sudden pain in
his back there was a slight whistle then
another sharp Spike of pain there were
now two arrows sticking out of his back
Abel turned surprised and saw a much
large future Force standing behind him
Swordsmen archers men with clubs and
axes and chains the ones he'd kill were
little more than a distraction this was
the real threat this was a real army
perhaps these fools would give him some
actual exercise he reached into his
cloak and pulled out a mighty obsidian
battle ax at the very least he tried to
have a little fun turning this fighting
force into cold cuts a fog of arrows
sailed through the air as he charged
forwards Perforating his body but the
injuries didn't slow him down he lunge
slashed and cleaved even as the weapon
struck him he carried on killing person
after person at times it was almost
exciting almost but not quite by the
time he was done none were left standing
30 arrows were sticking out of him he'd
been cut deep by more weapons than he
could count on his fingers and toes he
was breathing deeply scarred chest
pumping up and down he coughed blood and
cracked his neck back into place they
might have cut him a little too deep
this time no matter Abel fell to his
knees feeling the life draining from him
he wondered when he awoke from the
coffin again what the world would look
like sometimes it was days sometimes
weeks months or even years as he fell
forward dying once again he'd hoped that
he'd wake into a world with a warrior or
beast that could actually challenge him
maybe someday this was one of Abel's
many lives hundreds of years before he
was contained by the SCP Foundation he's
perhaps The Greatest Warrior who ever
lived died and lived again he's a man so
individually deadly that not only is he
kept in a containment chamber Under the
Sea surrounded by highly trained and
armored guards he has his own localized
on-site nuclear weapon ready to blow
away and annihilate him and his entire
containment area if deemed necessary he
may not be a contagious anomalous
pathogen or lethal memetic Hazard or a
giant Beast shooting World destroying
Fireballs in every direction but if this
one-man Massacre was left to his own
devices there's no doubt that he would
methodically Slaughter his way through
the human race until an XK Class end of
the world scenario was practically
inevitable he was fueled by pure hatred
and an almost bottomless bloodlust he
simply lived to fight and kill and not
only did he have the will and the skill
to be a pure force of annihilation but
his anomalous abilities also make him
perfectly tailored to the task he has
massively enhanced physical strength
speed and durability taking the kind of
damage that would kill several normal
humans to reliably put him down though
even that is only a temporary measure
Abel will always resurrect back into his
black sarcophagus to Menace the SCP
Foundation another day it is also
effectively impossible to disarm Abel
because he has the anomalous ability to
pull deadly edged weapons from localized
pocket demand tensions at will and his
proficiency with these weapons is unlike
any Warrior the world has ever known
before or since during containment
breaches he's regularly killed scores of
trained Foundation guards with both
numerical advantages and considerably
more advanced ranged weapons despite
being a simple humanoid he was taking up
a truly insane amount of containment
resources despite his violent tendencies
Abel is still a recognizable sentient
human albeit an extremely deadly
anomalous one this led some higher-ups
at the foundation to come up with an
interesting idea what if Abel's Eternal
rage could be harnessed what if they
could use their resources to reshape
this rampaging killer into a devoted
sword of the foundation's cause after
all if he wanted worthy opponents what
could be more worthy than the anomalous
monsters that the foundation faced on a
daily basis and as long as they kept the
sarcophagus even if Abel was killed in
the line of duty he'd still be accounted
for in many ways if he could be trained
and truly brought to heal there could be
no better asset to their coming
struggles it was this logic allowing
anomalies to work for the SCP Foundation
in exchange for benefits that led to the
creation of a new groundbreaking mobile
task force MTF
omega-7 Pandora's Box this group became
the SCP foundation's Hail Mary pass for
any particularly dangerous or
potentially deadly missions they could
send in able along with a group of
highly trained Foundation soldiers that
even the ancient blade-wielding warrior
held respect for while like their
namesake Pandora's Box it would all wind
up in terrible tragedy to begin with
they achieved some of the highest
mission successful results of any mobile
task force on the foundation's payroll
no task was too challenging for them to
swoop in and crush it this was far from
expected able one of the most violent
scps they've ever contained suddenly
became a great asset to their operations
a vital tool in their quest to keep the
anomalous at Bay he cleaved through
Legions of chaos Insurgency soldiers
during breaches into their secure sites
he fought off well-paid well-trained and
well-armed Bodyguards of Marshall Carter
and dark limited during Foundation raids
on their clandestine operations he'd
even gone Toe to Toe with some of the
deadliest anomalies in containment
during mass escapes it was hard to
imagine how they'd ever lived without
him of course while Abel was happier
than he'd had been in years in his
element in fact as a working Warrior
giving varied missions and frequent
opponents there was still something
nagging at him his thoughts were hounded
by his white whale the endless search
for a truly worthy opponent someone or
something that could really give him a
run for his money after Millennia of
leaving opponents dead in this wake
nothing would bring him more joy than
meeting someone that actually knocked
him on his ass an new bar somewhere
above him to work towards oh what a
glorious day that would be eventually
the foundation started to run into a
problem they were running out of
missions to give Abel after all he
wasn't the kind of operative you could
just give any mission to his potential
for collateral damage was truly
staggering he'd neutralized the anomaly
then Slaughter everyone within a hundred
foot range just to work off some of the
excess energy like a hand grenade he was
powerful but dangerously imprecise if
they ran out of high priority missions
what were they supposed to do just put
Abel back in his box to gather dust
until someone else rolled around he was
getting antsy enough between missions
already that's when an unexpected member
of personnel stepped forward Dr Jack
Bright you see Dr Brighton Abel had a
history and not an altogether Pleasant
one not that anyone could really have a
pleasant history with Abel Jack was only
a junior researcher when he had his
run-in carrying a seaming worthless
Medallion dubbed scp-963 back to its
containment Locker that's when a wall
next to him exploded showering him with
brick fragments and dust only to reveal
Abel standing behind the new aperture
before young Dr bright even had a chance
to scream Abel had already cleaved
through him leaving him in two distinct
parts that were both very much dead at
least it seemed that way until it was
revealed that Dr Bright's Consciousness
had actually been eternally bonded with
scp-963 giving him the gift and curse of
immortality since then Dr bright had
become increasingly reckless in his
conduct perhaps hoping that the next
time he Fades to Black the movie that is
his sad Strange Life won't just start to
roll again of course he hasn't been
lucky in that regard yet naturally this
has given Dr bright complex feelings
about his fellow anomalous Foundation
employee so when the call came around
all the the senior researchers and site
directors asking if there were any tasks
that Abel seemed fit for he had one very
pressing suggestion after all it wasn't
that long after Dr bright had been
forced into a cross test with the
intention of terminating 682 which had
not only been a failure but a generally
painful and exhausting experience now
perhaps it would be Abel's turn to take
his lumps he happily put forth a
suggestion claiming that surely the
foundation's new sword wielding Golden
Boy could give the hard to destroy
reptile the old College try after all
even if Abel was killed in the process
he'd just come right back it was a
situation where they really could not
lose so why not take a chance what's the
Worst That Could Happen the o5 council
found Dr Bright's pitch extremely
compelling he succeeded in every Mission
they'd given him so far so perhaps he
could carry that success into the
Herculean task of actually terminating
682 one boundlessly bloodthirsty killer
might be the only thing truly capable of
taking out another of equal magnitude
when Abel was informed of this latest
Mission he got a scary glint in his eye
they gave him warning after warning the
Beast is said to be unkillable it can
adapt to anything it's killed scores of
people and survived the attacks of
anomalies thought to be Flawless Killers
the more it was explained to him the
more Abel felt the tingling sensation
deep within was this it had he now
discovered the perfect opponent
something that would actually challenge
him would actually put him through his
Paces yes yes yes
he accepted the mission without question
Abel would fight
scp-682 until his breath was no longer
in order to prepare for the match
scp-682 was released into a secure area
Rocky desert-like terrain boarded on all
sides by a foundation perimeter hundreds
of meters away on on all sides they
thought it best for The Showdown to
happen here after all with combatants
like Abel and 682 it was bound to make a
mess one way or another Abel Strode with
pronounced Swagger onto the Battleground
shortly afterwards carrying perhaps the
most powerful sword he'd ever summoned
it was somewhere between a claymore and
a chainsaw an Unholy Union that gave the
resulting weapon a degree of deranged
badassery not ever seen on the
battlefields of planet Earth before
carrying this thing Abel felt like a
king and he was about to slay the most
ancient and bestial of monsters as he
approached 682 and took in the whole of
it he could feel his heart pounding with
excitement in his chest it was a huge
reptilian nightmare he could see its
scales hardening into a mighty carapace
as he approached its huge serrated fangs
its bulging sinewing muscles an insane
dagger-like claws oh oh yes this would
be the one the Beast snarled at him as
he approached he just smiled puffed out
his chest and said I have heard Tales of
creatures like you glorious beasts of
scale and flesh Talon and Fang a prowess
in battle even greater than the immense
intellect hiding behind those beastial
eyes they said your kind once Ruled the
Earth from enormous stockpiles of
treasure killing and eating all who
displeased you but you were knocked from
your throne one by one by the great
warriors who walk this world no longer
until they were no more and you became
but a mere myth even I had thought you
to be nothing but fairy tales but yet
here you stand before me a living dragon
in response to Abel's lofty speech the
monster merely grumbled and shouted him
claiming he was little more than a
pathetic SCP Foundation laptop following
orders and being manipulated it showed
no respect for Abel as a valued enemy
compatant merely another nuisance thrown
at it in a futile attempt to finish its
wretched and seemingly eternal life Abel
couldn't take such insolence he left
forwards bringing down his mighty
chainsaw Claymore ready to cleave the
beast in two however what he didn't
expect was the move
scp-682 pulled next throwing its head up
against the blade of Abel's sword
shredding away huge chunks of Flesh and
Bone an utterly confusing Abel in the
process for the first time in a lifetime
of intense battles Abel found himself
thinking what the hell am I up against
here the force of 682's headbutt threw
able off balance leaving his stomach
briefly exposed but briefly was all
scp-682 needed it thundered its massive
Stony fist into Abel's gut throwing him
like a ragdoll into a nearby
with such a force that it nearly
shattered The Rock behind him it was a
force like he hadn't felt in years he
spat some bloody teeth and grinned this
was just what the doctor ordered he
issued a challenge to the beast in a
long dead language as it seized
violently regenerating growing taking on
the Stony qualities of the ground around
it it looked like a vengeful living
Mountain a true Behemoth of a beast in
other words challenge accepted Abel
pulled an obscenely giant maze from the
shadows of his cloak the handle six feet
long with a chaos of swirling blades and
spikes a perfect weapon for slaying a
dragon like this he thought to himself
the two charged at each other full of
power and fury Abel swung the mace once
again shattering the creature's head and
flinging it back across the battlefield
with the sheer force of its strike the
decimated lizard clawed its way into the
ground devouring the rocks in the Earth
integrating more matter to fuel its
regeneration but it wasn't long before
Abel was upon it again striking
mercilessly giving blows as the monster
gave brutal claw strikes in return they
were ripping each other's bodies apart
piece by piece but Abel felt so
exhilarated he could barely even notice
it was the fight of his life a battle
against a truly worthy opponent this was
Heaven Abel leaped into the air and
Unleashed a volley of deadly chakram
down onto the Beast shredding into its
reinforced flesh as the force of gravity
brought him down he pulled a mighty Ax
from his cloak and bellowed A Warrior's
Roar as he brought it down splattering
into the nightmarish body of
scp-682 however this did nothing to even
slow the Beast Down it flipped over
slashing Abel with its claws when Abel
stumbled it leaped on top of him
unleashing devastating slashes and
punches onto the Fallen Warrior with the
speed of a machine gun firing when it
raised its claw to deal with the killing
blow though Abel once again turned the
tables he produced a giant pair of
mechanical scissors from thin air and
sliced off both of
scp-682's four legs the Beast descended
with its Mighty Jaws to devour Abel but
he kicked up with freakish strength
behind his bladed boot the sheer force
of the kick flipped scp-682 onto its
back now it was Abel's turn to execute
his opponent though on some level he
thought it would be an awful shame to
lose such a terrific beast from this
world of cardboard still a battle is a
battle and this is how they go he jumped
onto 682 and went berserk slashing into
it relentlessly with blade after blade
pulling out a new one every time the old
one broke down from his sheer ferocity
he screamed an incoherent battle Fury
tearing slicing ripping rending yes yes
yes yes as Abel stepped away to breathe
the Beast began to regenerate releasing
a shock wave that started to warp
reality around it but Abel wouldn't have
this no he would give this Beast No
Quarter it was time to present the true
pain he was Notorious for he pulled a
long sword from his cloak and charged
taking air and bringing it down towards
scp-682's head the Beast sensing the
Warrior's presence opened its mouth
unleashing a Chasm of horrifying teeth
within the two were on a fierce
collision course as the Jaws closed Abel
descended both roared in infinite rage
and bloodlust both combatants fell to
the ground just twitching oh what a
glorious terrible day it had been
neither had died for good but both would
remember this incredible battle forever
when Abel awoke once more in his dark
stone coffin he did so with a smile what
a battle what a fight what a truly
honorable Pursuit after so long being
bored and unfulfilled he found an
opponent that got his blood pumping once
more his stomach crumbled a post-battle
feast was an order now where did they
put that magic pizza box does the black
moon howl no not yet see the boy he was
born in a time before names there
weren't enough humans around to need
them back then he was one of a handful
occupying a Coastal Village using a
tongue long since dead they eked out a
simple life hunting Gathering fishing
the only thing on most of their minds
was surviving to see the next sunrise
yes a simple life free of complications
until the hermit appeared the boy would
remember this man for eternity Haggard
and thin skin weathered by time and pain
a man that emaciated it walking with a
long gnarled cane that honestly looked
healthier than he did shouldn't be alive
even the boy who had scarcely seen
beyond the bounds of his village knew
that the hermit was unnatural an
aberration an anomaly he walked into the
center of the village sat down on a
large Stone and waited nobody dared ask
his business nor what the hermit waited
for then a few days later the black moon
howled the boys saw The Village's
youngest Hunter freeze one evening while
out on a walk not simply stand still but
freeze then for an instant he became
solid black a coal statue and as soon as
he'd changed he was gone obliterated not
a trace of him remained such is the
power of the black moon it can make any
conscious being disappear in an instant
turn black then wiped from our plane of
existence never to be seen again its
choice of victims seemed at each
instance to be utterly random but it
would come for all who lived eventually
this is known to some as the howling of
the black moon later that same night the
boy found himself talking to the hermit
who asked with small frantic eyes what
he had seen when the boy told him he let
out a deep rattling sigh the boy curious
asked him if he knew about the nightmare
he just witnessed The Hermit looked up
he'd been the first one in the hermit's
Millennia of pursuit that had ever asked
in that moment he knew that he had found
his successor in the hunt for the death
of Ages The Hermit told the boy it went
by many names the great finale The Pale
King but most common of all was the
black moon The Entity existed Beyond the
Veil of our reality a creature of pure
energy
though nobody could really be sure of
its true nature The Hermit had been
tracking it learning about it and trying
to destroy it for thousands of years and
yet it only took him four pathetic
minutes to tell the boy everything he
knew the boy knowing still that
something about the hermit was unnatural
asked how he came to be in this position
The Hermit told the boy he was the
counterbalance a kind of Chosen One dust
into face and perhaps even defeat the
black moon someday the counterbalance
receives a number of truly extraordinary
gifts for inheriting the responsibility
eternal life
eternal youth near physical immortality
but they will be haunted by their
purpose doomed to watch everyone they
love die around them as they continue to
hunt their only true equal and opposite
the black moon itself The Hermit in his
own eyes had failed at his duty he had
grown Theory and now he needed to pass
the duty of counterbalance onto another
that other would be the boy he felt a
sudden and profound change along with
the knowledge that nothing would ever be
the same again he was no longer just the
boy now he was the counterbalance he
watched The Hermit give him a slight
knot of respect and then crumble into
dust before his eyes the boy the
counterbalance looked up at the sky and
saw the Stars twinkling so bright and so
beautiful little did he know his battle
with the black moon would Outlast every
single one of them does the black moon
howl not without blood the boy grew into
a man as his village aged and then died
around him decades passed then centuries
then Millennia tens of thousands of
years watching Humanity develop and grow
around him as he continued his pursuit
of that one elusive foe as science and
diagnostic technology gained ground
absorbing and then evolving beyond all
the old superstitions the counterbalance
gained a better understanding of the
black moon though even then it still
remained essentially a stranger The
Entity was entropic a being of pure
Randomness and Chaos without consistent
form it didn't exist in our universe but
it could exercise its influence here
with so-called obliteration events much
like the horrible fate that befell the
young hunter from the village but that
was only the proverbial tip of the
iceberg the counterbalance tracked and
noted obliteration events they were
exceedingly rare at first something that
occurred once every thousand years or so
like a terrible curse but he couldn't
help but notice a concerning Trend
emerging it started happening once a
century then once a decade he could feel
the terrible future stretching out in
front of him how over their shared
eternity the black moon would gain more
and more ground would there come a day
where it took someone once a year once a
month a week a day an hour a minute a
second he'd spell the end of all
conscious life a total victory for the
black moon the end of the universe the
death of Ages a complete existential
obliteration he was swept up in a
sobering realization he couldn't win
this fight alone however while his hunt
for the black moon had been largely
fruitless the counterbalance had
discovered many other things along the
way strange creatures objects with
extraordinary powers and events that
couldn't be explained with rational
science perhaps something about these
Oddities
these anomalies would hold the key to
defeating his Timeless enemy and it
hadn't just been these objects entities
and events he had also discovered some
truly exceptional people on his travels
minds and skills that rivaled even his
own despite his age perhaps they would
be the ones to help him win with the 13
most brilliant and trusted people the
counterbalance ever met he decided to
form a council and from this Council
they forged and directed an organization
dedicated to understanding and
counteracting the strange in all its
forms with the secret hope that their
search Into Darkness would yield the
answer to the black Moon's downfall he
called it the SCP Foundation they would
secure the anomalous contain it and
protect all of humanity from its
influence the counterbalance also took
on a new title The Fitting of his new
role the administrator and even the
black moon itself was given a moniker in
hopes of robbing it of some of its
frightening power
scp-001 does the black moon howl all
only at the blind the year was now 1987.
the SCP Foundation had been operating
for over a century and thanks to their
secret possession of anomalous wisdom
and Technology their own advancement was
thousands of years ahead of the rest of
humanity while there still wasn't a
silver bullet solution to the black moon
and its deadly howls were becoming all
the more frequent as the decades went on
the foundation did have some irons in
the fire to combat it their ability to
gather Intel on both the entity itself
and its obliteration events had improved
considerably thanks to their new Global
Information Network their top Minds were
also working on a highly classified
device known as the singular conceptual
bunker which may one day come in handy
for combating the extra dimensional
entity directly but the most valuable
piece of information they ever gathered
about the black moon was this it
couldn't howl when it was being watched
the very Act of engaged observation de
fanged it the problem is How Can You
observe something that doesn't
technically exist inside your own
reality in order to pull this off the
foundation would need to get extremely
creative thankfully Creative Solutions
to strange problems are the foundation
specialty Flash Forward to 1993 enter Dr
Moto a brilliant young scientist and
conceptual engineer working for the SCP
Foundation with the administrator's
consultation he started the key project
an arm of the wider project oromasides
the umbrella Initiative for using
modified anomalous objects in the battle
against the black moon the goal of the
key project was relatively simple if
people couldn't observe the black moon
directly then the foundation could make
proxies of the black moon that could be
observed almost like a kind of voodoo
doll these new anomalies would only need
to satisfy three criteria the inability
to operate when being observed a
hostility to conscious life and the
ability to end conscious life of their
own volition when not being observed
through conceptual engineering a link
theoretically could be forged between
these objects and the black moon
allowing observation of them to stop the
obliteration events however despite
being a good idea in theory Dr Moto's
efforts were marred with errors and
tragedies one object wasn't deadly
enough simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren't
looking another one killed purely
through collateral damage a giant
sculpture of a human head that
immediately attempted Escape by barging
through site-01 the center for
anti-black Moon operations and killing
19 people in the process another one of
Moto's objects a huge black sphere
simply immediately exploded killing 12
people and in the most horrific misstep
of all one of Moto's objects caused a
mass death event in a nearby hotel where
142 people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object a series of
interlocking stalactites and stalagmites
were left unobserved for 0.2 seconds
almost all of Moto's objects were
terminated in the aftermath either being
too useless or too dangerous to keep
around the young scientists felt a deep
shame but forged on he made one truly
brilliant creation that satisfied all
the criteria a sculpture incapable of
moving while being watched but would
snap the neck of the nearest conscious
entity if it left unobserved for even a
fraction of a second its relatively
minimal killing left it easy to contain
without causing Mass deaths and despite
all the other deaths that had sadly
occurred during the key project Dr Moto
believed that the lives saved in the
long run by stopping the black Moon's
howls would justify the sacrifice the
problem is the key project didn't stop
anything not long after this there was
the first recorded double obliteration
event in Rome where a young tourist
couple had both been obliterated
simultaneously all all the deaths in the
key project had been for nothing the
black moon was only getting more
powerful the shame in the guilt was too
much for Dr Moto he left a note in his
office Reading we've been looking at
nothing I'm sorry administrator I failed
you sir Moto's corpse was later found in
the sculpture's temporary containment
chamber his neck snapped the key project
was in summary shut down and its one
surviving creation transported to site
19 in late 1993 where it was designated
as
SCP-173 another painful failure for the
administrator back to the drawing board
once more does the black moon howl not
while the stars shine Millennia
stretched on almost everyone died except
the administrator thanks to his gift or
perhaps curse as the counterbalance to
the black moon science marched on the
SCP Foundation marched on but all this
progress all this power was not nothing
against the incomprehensible influence
of
scp-001 the black moon was howling more
frequently than ever all the way up to
the year 3156 when the foundation
launched the seek project under the
support of project oromastes as more and
more people were wiped out in frequent
obliteration events the administrator
became painfully aware that perhaps the
answers to the black moon problem
wouldn't be found on Earth using
state-of-the-art technology With a
Little Help from the anomalous the SCP
Foundation began work on an autonomous
space-faring vessel that could search
the stars for the key to the black
Moon's destruction it was an
awe-inspiring creation a huge craft
powered by artificial intelligence with
a universal translator cryogenic units
and hundreds of autonomous drones to
perform more targeted searches Zeke was
waved off into the unforgiving depths of
space the administrator could only hope
that it would come back with worthwhile
answers the first of the three notable
planets seek derived on was one
theoretically capable of supporting
human life except for its brutal and
constant blizzards and snowstorms when
sikh's drones were deployed they did
discover signs of civilization based
around sentient spherical creatures but
no signs of actual life remained records
and statues found across the planet seem
to indicate that the black moon was
responsible for the destruction of the
planet's civilization causing so many
obliteration events that the remaining
survivors went mad from the fear and
stress leading to mass death in the
ensuing chaos the next planet was
discovered centuries later in the year
3499 while this planet could also
theoretically support human life it
suffered from frequent volcanic
eruptions that rendered much of its
surface a flaming Mass however there
were still the dormant ruins of a once
Advanced civilization of conscious
beings much like the prior Planet they'd
been driven extinct by Black Moon
obliteration events as century before
the Sikh even arrived unlike the last
planet however it seems that they
accepted their fate and went gently into
the night the planet was now overrun by
billions of armored bat-like creatures
that operated on pure Instinct and thus
were not considered conscious enough to
be obliterated the final planet was
reached in 3764 and was the most
fruitful of the three discoveries this
planet was hyper Advanced fully
urbanized and covered in sprawling mega
cities with records and Technology over
a thousand years ahead of Earth before
the black moon killed almost all of them
there were a species of humanoid
telepathic fungi and that developed an
awareness of the black Moon's existence
that was on par with that of humanities
they even had their own equivalent of
the SCP Foundation actively working on
countermeasures and most amazingly of
all seek found one surviving member of
the species on the planet cryogenically
frozen The graft was immediately
instructed to collect the Survivor and
return home for interrogation the
administrator Was preparing for what
could be the most important conversation
since he met the hermit all those
thousands of years ago does the black
moon howl only when waning when the
surviving creature codenamed saged was
returned to Earth the administrator was
eager to finally speak with it like the
rest of its now extinct species Sage
spoke through powerful telepathic mind
waves which only the administrator
thanks to his counterbalance abilities
was able to receive at close range
without being harmed incidentally it
wasn't long until the very fact of the
administrator's nature as a
counterbalance came up in the mental
conversation Sage could tell just by
being in his presence they discovered a
number of vital truths over their brief
time communicating that Sage's survival
had been pure luck for starters the
black moon is still very much capable of
obliterating conscious beings in an
unconscious State the administrator also
learned that he was nearly the latest in
an extremely long line of
counterbalances across time space and
species though everyone but him had
waved this Duty passed it on Sage had
one question to ask the administrator in
turn what is SCB the singular conceptual
bunker being worked on and perfected for
thousands of years by now by the
foundation's top scientists and
conceptual Engineers the administrator
replied Victory but it will take a very
very long time specifically so long that
he would see the stars go out around him
one by one shocked saged asked him what
good victory would do him then rather
than say it aloud he replied with a
thought Sage paused and said I see how
Blasphemous of you hopefully it works
after this the administrator proceeded
to the singular conceptual bunker and
entered it leaving instructions for the
foundation to be run by a newly formed
o5 Council in his in indefinite absence
thousands of years later in the year
5011 Sage spoke one more time repeating
the words hopefully hopefully before
turning solid black and disappearing the
black moon had claimed one more victim
but billions more had gone in the
interim the administrator had no more
answers to give at least no more answers
that anyone but him would understand he
was inside the singular conceptual
bunker now loaded into a device known as
Tome an experimental Memorial module
meant to pick up and record all the last
messages of every dying civilization
Across the Universe when the time
finally came all he could do was wait
and wait was exactly what we did does
the black moon howl yes yes it does
years pass too many to count it's a time
after names now and Tome sits in the
very center drinking in the end of the
universe the last of all the human
colonies Across the Universe were
obliterated by the Black Moon back in
the years 73-29 so so so so long ago but
some of the final messages of fear panic
and distress still echoed around in the
administrator's mind hello is there
anyone here
we require assistance there's it's it's
taking people every day we need help
there's barely anyone left we need help
hello hello come on zero nine four three
we have abandoned the false flesh we
have abandoned the false flesh the
shepherd's crook broke beneath my knee
Cabo zero nine four three come on zero
nine four three forgive us forgive us
we're going to leave this on it's so
dark outside now it's blotted out the
sun it's I have to go now respond First
Convenience emergency
situation developing require additional
resources my [ __ ] your fault our fault
my fault your fault our fault my fault
your fault awful remember
and a small child the last on Earth
simply asking hello into an indifferent
microphone but the administrator had to
wait as the singular conceptual bunker
became the solitary conceptual bunker he
was the last conscious being in the
universe and still he needed to wait as
the Stars went dark outside only when
there was nothing outside but black was
it finally time for the counterbalances
long game to play off there was nothing
left of our universe the only thing here
was the SCB and the black moon itself
with everything else gone the black moon
only had one conscious being left to
obliterate it opened the door to the
solitary conceptual bunker and stepped
inside this this doesn't make sense how
can the black moon an entity beyond our
Dimension Beyond physical form take a
step good question the same question
incidentally that was going through the
black Moon's mind as it entered the
bunker it didn't look at all how the
entity expected it was like a bar a
counter with rows of bottles behind it a
jukebox playing in the corner a man
stood behind the bar cleaning the
glasses the counterbalance the
administrator he said well there you are
certainly took your time can I pour you
a little something this only served to
increase the black Moon's confusion it
had form here dark smoke compressed into
a vaguely humanoid shape it could speak
it could think none of this may made any
sense the being that had just wiped out
all conscious life and seen the very
death of the universe was truly and
utterly confused the administrator just
seemed to be enjoying himself preparing
for a confrontation hundreds of billions
of years in the making the singular
conceptual bunker or perhaps the
singular containment bunker was a truly
ingenious creation a place of pure ideas
where everything inside was on the same
level here there were no Immortals no
Gods just ideas on the same Level
Playing Field and it was time for the
black Moon's idea to come to an end it
was a trap and the entire universe was
the bait without warning the
administrator pulled up a shotgun from
underneath the table and Unleashed both
barrels into the black Moon's chest the
creature took the head and fought back
dragging the administrator to the ground
beating him strangling him he could feel
the light fading under the mount
Monster's Relentless assault until he
managed to get his desperate hands on a
glass ashtray he'd beat the monster over
the head with it until it's gripped
loosened and he was able to slide out
there the killer of the universe was on
the ground before him he grabbed the
monster held it in place and beat it to
death he was Gravely injured by the
battle but the black moon was no more
here in the singular conceptual bunker
he had won the administrator no longer
the counterbalance in the absence of the
black moon hobbled over to the Jukebox
produced a single beautiful coin from
his pocket he pushed the coin into the
slot wheezed a pain breath and said the
thing is this place is only information
there's nothing else out there not even
matter the universe closed its doors a
long time ago this place can go from
information back to matter with just the
Press of a button
let's see what happens when we introduce
something to nothing for a second it
looks as though he might fall but he
doesn't instead he slams the button on
the jukebox and with a relieve laugh
says let there be light and there was
light from gigantic indestructible
self-regenerating reptiles to enormous
tentacled telepathic organisms it should
come as no surprise that the SCP
Foundation has gone head to head against
a lot of large-scale aggressors or lsas
in its time naturally a creature of
heightened size and aggression can often
prove challenging to contain and the
threat these lsas pose is often far too
big to ignore but anyone familiar with
the foundation will tell you they're not
above using any methods necessary to
keep these creatures contained huge Vats
of molecular acid impenetrable cells
disposable d-class Personnel even other
scps but what other scps could possibly
be big enough and tough enough to handle
some of the foundation's biggest and
baddest meet
scp-5514 otherwise known as the dragon
slayer while it might sound like
something out of an anime
scp-5514 is a massive robotic Mech
designed to take on the worst other scps
can throw at it for any who are
unfamiliar with the term a Mech or Mecca
usually refers to an upright standing
machine or automaton controlled by a
human pilot what distinguishes a Mech
from a vehicle is their often humanoid
shape standing by petally and they are
often hundreds of meters tall all of
this is true of scp-5514 and in fact
given that it requires a trained member
of foundation staff to operate it the
mech itself requires very little in the
way of containment only members of
mobile task force Ada 5 are trained and
authorized to Pilot
scp-5514 this is one of the SCP
foundation's specialized units
specifically designed to deal with the
threat of large-scale aggressors much
like
scp-5514 itself but scp-5514 wasn't
discovered or captured by the foundation
for use for the containment of lsas nor
was it stolen from a foreign military or
found buried under the ground then where
did it come from and who built it
working with the global occult Coalition
and the government of high Brazil an
anomalous island off the west coast of
Ireland the foundation themselves
constructed
scp-5514 using various anomalous methods
and techniques in 1988 a foundation site
was destroyed by an unidentified LSA
highlighting the inadequacy of the
current defenses against these larger
more damage resistant creatures the
foundation the Coalition and high Brazil
formed a joint operation the key project
and examined
scp-2406 an automaton 93 meter tall
thought to be created by ancient
mccainites together the key project
opted to create their own similar
machine viewing it as the best way to
defend against further incursions with
large-scale aggressors the construction
of scp-5514 began in 1990. the intention
of all parties involved in the key
project including the foundation was
that the dragon slayer would be deployed
in the event of an attack by an LSA it
would arrive at cities under attack and
immediately engage large-scale
aggressors in combat building of the
mech continued at a consistent pace for
eight years however it was the
occurrence of
scp-5391 and subsequent intervention by
the o5 council that accelerated the
creation of the Dragon Slayer by any
means necessary on June 30th 1998 a
number of seismic disturbances were
detected including tsunamis Tremors and
volcanic activity both underwater and
above ground What followed was the
appearance of multiple large-scale
aggressors which would soon become
designated as
scp-5391 the exact kind of scenario that
the dragon slayer was being built for
had already arrived and the mech was
still far from completion while the
foundation and its allies deployed
forces to drive the enormous creatures
back to the ocean something needed to be
done to bring
scp-5514 into the fight and fast the o5
council authorized the use of anomalous
materials in the continued construction
of the Dragon Slayer both to speed up
the process and have it ready for
deployment but also to give the mech
every advantage against the abundance of
large-scale aggressors from
scp-5391 as a result
scp-5514 was designed to incorporate
features and Technology far beyond that
of any Conventional military-grade
Weapons the first hurdle how do you
power a machine the size of
scp-5514 naturally with the most
gigantic nuclear your furnace there is
the sun more specifically a perpetually
stable miniaturized Sun known as
scp-037 even though it only has a
diameter of two inches this little
sucker is better than premium fuel the
surface temperature of scp-037 is around
5000 Kelvin generating plenty of energy
to power the scp-5514 mech stored in the
dragon slayer's chest this mini sun is
kept stable by sub-dimensional portals
that vent excess energy off this plane
of reality stopping the mech its pilot
and anything around it from melting in
fact scp-037 produces so much juice that
only one percent of its energy output is
enough to fully power
scp-5514 now that's the power source
sorted but how do you solve the weight
problem given the sheer size of scp-5514
it would be easy for it to be cumbersome
and potentially cause catastrophic
collateral damage to its surrounding
area while the Mac X Wade is a problem
for somewhere else a whole other
dimension in fact much like the excess
heat from its power source various heavy
portions of the scp-5514 mech have their
weight shunted off to a tiny pocket
Dimension it was insured during the
creation of the mech that this
alteration was perfectly calculated so
that scp-5514 wouldn't lose any mass or
density so it operates as if it were
only a fraction of its actual weight of
course being weightless makes flight a
whole lot easier oh did we forget to
mention that
scp-5514 can fly as well this feature
actually became a part of the mech
completely by accident during the
construction of
scp-5514 when an attempt to regulate the
max internal circulation of air led to
it having its own gravity field this
allowed scp-5514 to fly without the aid
of any turbines or other means while
this was an unintentional mistake no
attempt has ever been made to correct
for it for fear that it could lead to
scp-5514 being grounded permanently
naturally going up against creatures so
large that they require their own
subcategory means that scp-5514 needs an
equally formidable Arsenal so let's move
on to talk Weaponry mounted on the
mech's shoulder is a Beowulf cigarette
railgun an anomalous weapon that also
doesn't obey the laws of physics at all
the Beowulf cigarette uses alternate
gravity to affect the weight of its
targets causing projectiles to impact
with higher velocity even the thickest
skinned lsas wouldn't want to be staring
down the barrel end of one of those big
guns assigned the scp-5514 mech also
wields a cold iron sword over 65 feet
long this weapon was contributed to the
Dragon Slayer by the high Brazil Royal
Court members of the collaborative key
project that created the mech sure a
large-scale aggressor with thicker hide
might take a few extra swings to draw
blood but it will feel those swings for
a long time after since any wounds
inflicted by the cold iron sword will
not regenerate serving as less of an
offensive weapon the scp-5514 mech also
features a unique Armament known as the
Thousand word arrows as pretentious as
it might sound within the Mac are seven
poets their role is to ride and recite
poems that detailed the slaying of
monsters and these recitals are then
broadcast from the dragon slayer on the
surface this seems to have no practical
applications during a fight with lsas
however the goal of the Thousand word
arrows is a form of psychological
warfare the recital of poems telling of
the mech's Victory and the defeat of
large-scale aggressors is intended to
have the effect of demoralizing
scp-5514's adversaries while encouraging
the pilot during combat additionally
warn Atop The Head of the scp-5514 mech
almost like a hat is a discus with
plasma coated edges if the dragon slayer
needs to deal damage at range then it
can hurl this disc and recall it
immediately thanks to built-in
electromagnets in emergency scenarios if
the cold iron sword is damaged or
dropped and irretrievable
scp-5514 is also equipped with an
additional melee weapon stored in the
right arm of the mech is a hold out
plasma wrist blade this superheated
blade is strong enough to cut through
almost anything however this blade is
strictly to be used as a backup weapon
finally should all else fail one of
scp-5514's greatest strengths can also
be used as a deadly weapon the emergency
Sun vent allows a fraction of the Excess
power from scp-037 to be released at the
risk of causing massive damage not only
to lsas but to any civilians or
structures nearby it is because of the
destructive risk involved that this
weapon is only authorized to be used as
a final Resort and luckily
scp-5514 is currently undefeated it
since the arrival of multiple
large-scale aggressors as a result of
scp-5391 the scp-5514 mech has managed
to successfully eliminate 12 of these
LSA creatures either by terminating or
otherwise incapacitating them given that
its completion was fast-tracked through
the use of anomalous elements
scp-5514's first combat deployments also
served as field tests of the mechs
operation and the various weapons and
features arriving in Tokyo overseen by
the foundation's own Captain Rosales and
Dr kaori
scp-5514's first Target was a creature
designated LSA wake 0-2 as well as
several other unidentified large
creatures as the LSA was about to attack
Tokyo Harbor
scp-5514 was dispatched its arrival
heralded by the Thousand word arrows
champion champion exalt in the glory of
the Dragon Slayer The Poets recited
surprisingly The Poetry weren't here
hearing it had a noticeable effect on
LSA wake 0-2 causing the creature to
back away shrieking with a single throw
of the rounded recoiling plasma
scp-5514 immediately beheaded wake 0-2
damaging a number of the other nearby
lsas as it retrieved the disc via its
electromagnets once again the Thousand
word arrows cheered on the mech in the
pilot reciting the vicious Beast slain
gone to those which were once Bain after
dispatching several of the minor lsas
with its cold iron sword
scp-5514 became aware that wake-02 was
not fully down for the count a second
head had protruded from the mouth of the
creatures first issuing some sort of
retreat call to the remaining lsas in
Tokyo Harbor this second head then shot
towards
scp-5514 narrowly missing its leg but
allowing other lsas to close the
distance and prepare an attack luckily
the scp-5514 Mex sword cleaved the beast
in two the mech began firing on the
remains of wake zero do with its Beowulf
cigarette railgun launching itself into
the air and flying towards the target
while bringing its cold iron sword down
through the air with a single motion
scp-5514 brought the blade all the way
down the LSA spine from the creature's
head to its caudal fin gutting the
large-scale aggressor and splitting its
entire body in two after one final
squirm both halves were finally still
scp-5514 had passed its first field test
the mech functioned exactly as designed
all its various weapons and features
working in tandem to defeat a creature
far too large and Powerful for any
conventional Force to handle and thus
the deed was done exalt exalt in the
glory of the Dragon Slayer the Thousand
word arrows called out as the other lsas
retreated one cannot help but feel
cautiously optimistic about our chances
of survival knowing that the foundation
as
scp-5514 as the first line of defense
against huge monstrous beings that
threaten Humanity as the situation with
scp-5391 continues the scp-5514 mech
remains on the front line standing
between innocent human beings and the
looming shapes of multiple large-scale
aggressors with creatures that pose such
a large-scale threat it certainly is
lucky that disparate groups were able to
put aside their differences and work
together to build a large-scale Mech and
because they did now we have the dragon
slayer on our side the year is 1939.
it's the dead of night in ping Fang a
district of the Harbin prefecture in
Japanese Imperial occupied China a
squadron of over a hundred Chinese
Rebels led by Lieutenant Wong Wei
clutching Bergman mp-18 machine guns
hurry through the streets towards their
destination the bioweapons lab operated
by Unit 731 and monstrous terrifying
Japanese surgeon General Shiro ishi it
is a mission of Liberation and revenge
if you know anything about Unit 731 just
hearing the name will send a chill down
your spine just as it did for the
Chinese soldiers hoping to perform a
surprise assault on the unit's complex
of Horrors rumors had spread from the
Chinese prisoners of War taken there and
the knowledge of the horrible things
happening to their countrymen inside
that building made their blood boil with
white hot Fury their mission was simple
they would launch an attack on the
complex when the unit least expected it
save as many prisoners as they could
while also taking revenge on as many
unit soldiers as they could get their
hands on but what the brave Soldiers
didn't know is that they were in for a
battle they couldn't hope to win because
what they were fighting was not in any
traditional sense human they were about
to go toe-to-toe with
scp-4007 an elite group of anomalous
Japanese super soldier is known as the
Ping Fang 5. a name spoken in fear by
their enemies and victims For What
Little Time both remained alive the
Chinese Rebels were hiding in a stand of
trees outside the Fortress waiting for
the right moment to strike when the Ping
Fang five suddenly beat them to the
punch and descended upon them the plan
was thrown into chaos when the trees
burst into flames without so much as a
hint of artillery being fired the
soldiers all hardened Men of War began
to grow scared but then they saw
something even more terrifying standing
there amongst the Flames first
lieutenant mitso Kitano also known as
lightning bolt or
scp-4007-1 to the foundation one of his
hands was wreathed in blue Sparks of
electricity and the others he wielded a
type 14 nambu pistol Lieutenant Kitano
continued his attack using his anomalous
lightning to blow away Soldier after
Soldier when the shocked Rebels tried to
return fire they found that they
couldn't land a single shot Gaetano
dodged every bullet the second wave of
the assault came from behind as the
rebels tried to flee katano's round
private Takashi Honda also known as the
ogre or
scp-4007-2 charged Into The Fray he
effortlessly wielded a type 11 machine
gun and Rain bullets down upon his
unsuspecting foes they shot back at him
but the bullets seemed to just bounce
off his skin he wasn't bothered by them
in the slightest he just smiled and
continued firing the rebels quickly
realized that the whole thing had been a
trap but what had given them away as if
On Cue one of their own soldiers turned
and began firing on his fellow Soldiers
with his MP18 this man wasn't a rebel in
fact he wasn't even Chinese it was
Corporal jochiro Ida also known as the
fox or
scp-4007-3 how could he have possibly
infiltrated the Squadron the answer is
simple he's an anomalously brilliant
liar in fact it's impossible to not
believe a single thing that Corporal Ida
says making him a true expert in
Espionage not a single one of the other
Rebels ever had a chance of sniffing him
out before the doomed Mission if this
betrayal surprised them then what came
next must have seemed like something out
of a nightmare Lieutenant Wong Wei the
man who'd spearheaded the entire Mission
turned and began picking off his own
troops with his pistol the surviving
soldiers didn't understand have the
lieutenant gone mad they tried to shoot
him but just like the others he dodged
effortlessly and continued to murder
them that's because he wasn't Lieutenant
Wong way at all way had been murdered in
the forest earlier that night and
replaced by private Terror nishimura
also known as
scp-4007-5 or the shapeshifter the Ping
Fang 5 had infiltrated and compromised
the mission from before it had even
begun they never even stood chance
during the chaos of the massacre a few
of the rebels had managed to escape
running through a nearby clearing into a
Thicket of trees if they could survive
then perhaps they could regroup and
leave a second assault on another day
they had no help of survival during a
head-on conflict with these anomalous
super soldiers they needed to get away
and form a new strategy but gunshots
started ringing out through the forest
tearing into their bodies and dropping
the men one by one they tried to return
fire but they couldn't even see who was
shooting at them it seemed to come from
all directions the rebels dying thoughts
were that the trees around them must
have been crawling with Japanese troops
the reality was even more frightening it
was only one man private Shigeru Matsui
codenamed smoke for this ability to
become invisible at will to the
foundation he's known as
scp-4007-4 the last member of the Ping
Fang five the deadliest troops in the
entire Imperial real Japanese Army but
unlike many of the biological anomalies
cataloged by the SCP Foundation the Ping
Fang 5 were not born they were made in
case you aren't familiar with the
infamous Unit 731 and their horrifying
complex in ping Fang this unit was the
secret Department of the Japanese Army
ordered into existence by Emperor
Hirohito himself for one Sinister
purpose researching chemical and
biological weapons for the Japanese
Imperial Army their leader the Surgeon
General Shiro ishi was essentially given
blanket permission to do whatever he
deemed necessary in order to achieve
results for his Emperor and his Nation
ishi took that directive and ran with it
unleashing pseudoscientific evil on the
level matched only by the Nazi
extermination camps in Europe
experimental weapons and horrific
diseases were tested on captured Chinese
civilians political dissidents and
prisoners of war thousands of people met
horrific ends through execution
experimentation and section which is the
dissection of a subject that is still
very much alive how does this relate to
the pingfang 5 and scp-4007 it all comes
back to a top secret project overseen by
ishi himself project shinka while Unit
731 was established in 1935. in 1937
they began working in collaboration with
the Imperial Japanese anomalous matters
examination agency think of it as
Imperial Japan's hypernationalist answer
to the SCP Foundation they had become
aware of the existence of anomalous
individuals in imperial-controlled
territories in general Yushi wanted to
know whether the powers manifested in
these anomalous individuals could be
induced in others through forced organ
removal and transplantation to test this
hypothesis ishi had the Japanese secret
police Roundup anomalous individuals in
Imperial territory on mass they were
subjected to mass vivisections with the
intention of isolating and removing
anomalous organs it was an act so
positively genocidal in proportion that
East Asia had statistically fewer
anomalous humans than they should to
this day ishi's intention was to
transplant the organs into loyal
volunteers from the Japanese military in
order to create an unbeatable military
force perfect soldiers who would win the
war for them the vast majority of these
Twisted experiments were complete
failures leading to the higher-ups at
Unit 731 almost writing project shinka
off as a waste of time and canceling the
whole thing but there were soon five
notable exceptions the very scary
individuals you've already met not only
did every member of the Ping Fang 5 end
up with a specific anomalous superpower
as a result of the experiments they also
experienced incredible anomalous prowess
across the board members of the five
boast extended longevity meaning they
rarely show their age enhanced physical
abilities including faster reflexes
incredible senses and immense physical
strength they also appear to have
advanced mental development displaying
phenomenal tactical and strategic
reasoning as well as the ability to
effortlessly learn read and speak
multiple languages like Japanese English
Mandarin Chinese Russian and German of
course Japan eventually lost the war but
the Ping Fang 5 had no intentions of
ending their fight they continued their
missions long after Japan formally
surrendered causing chaos and violence
across East Asia after several
unsuccessful engagements with isolated
members of the Ping Fang five leading to
the deaths of many Foundation agents and
civilians the foundation formed mobile
task force 551 AKA MacArthur's dogs an
elite group of operatives trained for
the specific mission of Bringing Down
the Ping Fang five while the hunt rages
on three of the five are already dead
scp-4007-1 mitsuo Kitano the man who can
unleash bursts of electricity met his
and in Burma in 1948 during a procedure
called operation Smokehouse 551 engaged
katano in combat in the jungle as was
one of his trademark techniques he
attempted to use his electricity powers
to burn down the jungle and Escape
during the chaos however the foundation
operatives surrounded and boxed him in
he couldn't escape and when the fires
were put out he was found dead on the
ground the apparent cause of death was
smoke inhalation
scp-4007-2 Takashi Honda the man with
Bulletproof Skin died in 1957 in the
Philippines 551 engaged him in combat in
a mission dubbed operation homewrecker
which culminated in them calling down an
air strike on him in the aftermath Hondo
was found dead but his cause of death
was determined as having been from a
powerful electric shock and finally
scp-4007-3 jochiro Ida the man with the
silver tongue was found dead a year
later in 1958. his corpse was discovered
in his room room in guiang southern
China he appeared to have been strangled
to death and interestingly there was
evidence that he tried to engage in the
shootout with his killer but hadn't
succeeded in preventing his own murder
all these circumstances were somewhat
mysterious but the foundation didn't
investigate them much further after the
bodies were tagged and bagged
scp-4007-5 teronishimura the
shapeshifter is still on the run today
while
scp-4007-4 Shigeru Matsui The Invisible
Man is doing just the opposite he lives
in Sarawak Malaysia and works in open
cooperation with the SCP Foundation to
help track down the fifth member of the
Ping Fang five not much has changed in
the 64 years since the death of George
it seemed like the search for
scp-4007-4 had gone cold until a
foundation archival clerk found
something suspicious the original paper
copy of the scp-4007 document which was
dated a year before the foundation had
supposedly discovered the existence of
scp-4007 as the archival worker dug
further they found a number of
unsettling discoveries that alter the
true meaning of
scp-4007 in the original paper documents
each dead member of the Ping Fang 5 had
organs missing and each subsequent
member's death involved a power
possessed by a former member two was
electrocuted and three's gun was useless
as the killer had been wearing two's
Bulletproof Skin who was behind this why
and most importantly of all how had this
all been forgotten through more digging
the foundation discovered the truth
about
scp-4007-4 his powers weren't
invisibility they were anti-memetic he
can make people forget him at will
essentially editing their memories so he
could do whatever he wanted without
detection like for example murdering his
team members and stealing their powers
they even managed to find an archive
letter from four to three begging for
his help in fighting some kind of
unknown monster something that would
require their combined powers to face
whether they ended up being as five
separate men or one man with all of
their powers this whole time
scp-4007-4 had been playing the
foundation like a fiddle using their
resources to help him track down the
final member of the Ping Fang fine to
recruit him into one final mission or
murder him and steal his powers but that
still leaves one question what is this
Mission what is this monster the
foundation managed to find out at least
partially they charted the death
locations of each of the three dead ping
Fang members and the living location of
scp-4007-4 and discovered something
amazing four of the five points on a
perfect Pentagon centering on the South
China Sea the foundation also estimated
that the Pentagon would reveal the
location of
scp-4007-5 at the final point but his
location isn't nearly as interesting as
what resides at the center of this
massive geographical Pentagon Foundation
divers discovered huge numbers of sunken
Japanese battleships down planes and
thousands of Bones littering the seabed
based on the damages to these vessels it
was clear that they hadn't been shot or
blown up no they had been torn apart by
something obscenely huge and Powerful
underneath the water the Pentagon a
significant shape and sorcery is likely
a massive Supernatural containment
ritual keeping whatever unspeakable
horror is lurking under the ground there
from escaping a containment ritual that
could only be maintained by five special
individuals in five special places it
was in this moment that the foundation
Came Upon a truly horrifying Revelation
they had misjudged the intentions of
project shinka it was never about
creating assets for the war against the
Allies it was about a war against some
something else entirely something much
more dangerous than and deadly than the
squabbles between men it was about the
entity that lurked below a creature that
nobody understood and that no
conventional weapon can fight and if the
ritual is ever broken and the Beast is
allowed to rise the Ping Fang 5 will be
the very least of our problems I used to
complain about work all the time the
long hours the disrespect from my boss
getting home exhausted aching and
sunburnt I worked in construction a
lifetime ago I'd give anything to go
back to that now was that they always
say you don't know what you've got until
it's gone maybe I deserve the hand I've
been dealt I haven't been a good person
I don't play well with others there was
an argument with my four men one that
got a little too heated I just couldn't
reign in my temper the hammer I'd been
using all day was still in my hand but I
digress I used to build things with my
hands but I'm in a different line of
work now if you can call it work that
would imply I get paid I clock in every
morning and I get to go home afterward I
don't I'm a prisoner really a glorified
Lab Rat and property of the all-powerful
SCP Foundation I've been here about
three weeks and everyone always says
d-classes like us last about a month
here so uh clock is ticking down to zero
for me I haven't had to do anything too
dangerous yet but like I said it's just
a matter of time I'm sitting in my cell
the same windowless box I've spent every
day for the past three weeks when a god
bursts in and grabs me by the arm what's
going on I ask but he ignores me of
course I make conversation with a lab
rat better not to think of us as human
at all he Yanks me down the hall opens a
door and shows me inside there's several
other d-class in there already and
they're staring at something in the
corner that I can't quite make out I
start to turn around and to take a look
at the rest to the room but a voice
comes over the loudspeaker cold and
clinical look at the statue in the
corner do not take your eyes off it well
when a disembodied voice at the SCP
Foundation tells you to look at
something you better do it so I look
it's a sculpture made from concrete and
rebar it looks pretty harmless but I've
heard enough scream through the walls
and though they don't keep too many
harmless things caged up here whatever
this thing really is I don't want to
know what it'll do to me when my back is
turned I stare at it unblinking feeling
my eyes burn and tear up from the dry
air and concentration I'm scared to
close my eyes for even a second
determined not to be the first one in
here to break but something out there
has other plans for me for us I hear a
war glints sound like a motor struggling
to start the sudden crash of thunder
outside and then the room goes black for
a second I think I've gone blind but
then I hear the other guy screaming the
yelling scientist behind the wall so now
the power's gone I I can't see anything
but I can hear the sound of stone
scraping against itself the snap of
breaking bones a thought of a limp body
slumping over to the floor the room
comes into Focus again it's a backup
generator kicks in and fills the space
with weak fluorescent light but but
something's different something's wrong
the statue in the corner is gone the
other two men are on the floor heads
twisted around backwards and the doors
standing wide open is this a trap trick
of some kind if I run out that door will
a God be waiting there for me I don't
know but whatever might happen to me if
I try can't be any worse than what will
happen if I stay right here through the
wall I hear the sickening snapping sound
again a corpse thudding to the ground
they didn't plan this something in their
experiment went horribly wrong for them
maybe just maybe it went right for me I
don't give it a second thought I'm out
the door running through the dimly lit
holes through the Maze of identical
corridors in search of some kind of exit
all around me this chaos Gods firing
their weapons at inhuman shapes that I
catch a brief glimpse of as I run past
scientists yelling for help people going
as fast as they can towards danger and
away from it I'm so caught up in you
know I don't even notice when I run
right into a woman in the white lab coat
knocking us both to the ground I
scrambled to my feet and look her with
wide eyes waiting for her to turn me in
to call the gods but she doesn't uh I'm
so sorry astama she holds out of hand
gesturing for me to help her through her
feet so so I do watch her step there she
says with a known smile I can't help but
notice how beautiful she is twinkling
brown eyes and thick black hair then I
spot them tucked under her head but
unmistakable she has a pair of foxes on
top of her head it hits me in Rapid
succession then all the things about
this woman that don't look quite right
are unusually long nails too sharp and
pointed for lab work the Pharaoh glint
in her eyes that halting Cadence of a
voice this woman is not an employee of
the CP Foundation she's doing the same
thing I am taking advantage of the
situation to try to escape I'll uh be
more careful from now on man I say she
winks and turned down the hall I can see
a tail poking out beneath the bottom of
a lab coat safe travels I call after her
she laughs a dangerous sound like she's
not the one who needs to worry about
staying safe and I wonder what might
have happened if I had caught her in a
worse mood good thing my mom thought me
my Manus now which way should I go from
here should I follow the woman I get the
feeling she doesn't want to get company
and I prefer to stay on a good side as
I'm thinking it through I hear a small
popping sound behind me like a vacuum in
the air being filled all of a sudden I
spin around there's a guy standing there
ordinary as you please blonde hair green
eyes wearing jeans and a t-shirt that
says Mothman fan club and red lettuce
this guy looks pretty out of the place
well the type you'd see browsing a comic
book store but after my prior strange
encounter I know not to assume anything
him man what's going on he asked me I
stare back not sure what to say what I
miss he continues I feel like I was gone
for ages
um I just stood through our Collective
surroundings the sound of alarms Bland
and voices crying out for backup the
inhuman shrieks of creatures being
forced back into the cells there's a lot
going on huh yeah seems like it the guy
says you wouldn't happen to know how to
get out of here would you I ask
hopefully he shakes his head sorry I
don't really come and go through the
door here I guess I'll just go back to
my room until things calm down a bit you
want anything I got a mini fridge in
there the office no thanks suit yourself
man he shoves his hands back in his
pockets and walks away whistling a tune
to himself if he's this unfazed by
teleporting into the middle of a
complete madhouse I don't even want to
know what kind of stuff he's seen nice
enough kid though probably better
company than anyone or anything else in
this place if I'm not going to take him
up on his offer though I should keep
moving someone notices I'm not where I'm
supposed to be around the corner just in
time to see another body drop I whirl
around looking for that horrible statue
but I don't see it instead I see what
looks like a man dressed in all black
wearing a mask in the shape of a bird's
face with a long pointed beak he's
carrying like an old-school doctor's bag
and he's bending down to inspect the
body of the god that just killed over I
should keep running I should stew
something but I can't look away the man
in Black pulls a syringe full of thick
green liquid from his bag and injects it
into the corpse to my heart the body
begins to move thrashing around hands
opening and closing grasping for
something it sits up reanimated but
wrong its eyes are bulging and vacant
like a goldfish its mouth hangs slack as
this zombie climbs to his feet the
figure in all black turns to look at me
I shining from beneath his mask hello my
good fellow how are you feeling today he
calls to me his voice polished and
polite I'm fine I shout mine's shaking
chest type the doctor tilts his head to
the side thoughtfully you don't look
well my friend perhaps you could allow
me to examine you the zombie shuffled
towards me and the doctor opens his bag
there is this pestilence raging through
this land you see I'm not gonna stick
around to find out what that exam might
look like or what he might try to do in
the service of curing me no thanks I
don't have health insurance that is all
I can think to say as I turn and run the
way back I came I still have no idea
where an exit might be I might get out
of here it looks the same one long
stretch of tile and white I guess a
place like the foundation isn't gonna
have red neon signs down you how to
escape but this place can go on forever
can it I'm starting to have my doubts
before I can get too lost my own
hopelessness the biggest man I've ever
seen comes lumbering down the hall
toward me I work with some pretty big
guys in construction massive behemoths
who could carry steel beams like there
were pool noodles but this man something
else entirely he's gotta be like what
eight feet tall the fist that they look
like they could crush my skull in one
hit I better get out of this Monster's
way if I know what's good for me but as
he passes me and he waves and gives me a
great big friendly if unnaturally wide
smile
beautiful day isn't it he bellows in
that booming French accent The Voice
this other hand he picks his teeth with
something white a closer look reveals to
be a shot of bone I have to imagine it's
human his lips are stained dark with
blood you look lost can I help you with
something a helpful people eater
what a guy I keep my distance but beside
the time I look you wouldn't uh happen
to know where the exit is they say he
beams at me thrilled by my question I'm
so glad you asked he's this way he
points down the hall to the left just
follows that Hollows if you're down it
takes the only right that should get you
where you're going thanks give him a
wave back as I head that way as I go I
can hear the giant singing opera to
himself something Italian reminds me of
a record my grandma used to play a long
time ago maybe this will get me free
maybe it won't but it's more information
than I had a second ago might as well
give it a shot if you don't make it
through this I'm gonna be in the best
shape of my life from all the running
I've done today maybe I'll try to do a
marathon well maybe I shouldn't get
ahead of myself there's no one else down
this particular Hall at least no one
that I can cease I slow my Pace to a
steady walk in my eyes and ears alert
for any potential threats so far so good
reach the other side of the hall and
take a right turn and nothing just a
wall that giant son of a gun lied to me
I guess that's what I get for asking
accountable for directions I guess I'm
lucky just misled me instead of having
me for dessert I'm about to play my next
move when I feel something nudge against
the back of my leg I turn in this word I
can only describe as a blob just a large
mass of orange slime wrapped around my
legs making it friendly high-pitched
gurgle they should be suspicious of it
after everything I've seen but I'm not I
just get the feeling that this thing has
my best interest in her hey buddy I've
added slimy surface and it ripples
delightedly making another gurgling
sound it's kinda cute honestly I smell
the scent of freshly brewed coffee one
of my favorite smells in the world
I haven't had a decent Cup in years all
of a sudden I feel this overwhelming
sense of Happiness of Hope even if it's
foolish to think so I honestly believe
that everything's gonna be all right
it's strange little friendly slime has
given me the strength to carry on I wish
I had a plushy version of this thing
there's a sun tickling sensation along
my legs and I laugh pushing the Slime
away gently
it's not bad it cools apologetically and
bumps itself against me like a stray dog
asking for scratches behind the ears
Wonder for a second if I could take this
thing with me but what would I even feed
it what kind of life could I give a
domesticated slime creature better to
leave it with the people who know how to
care for it even if they're mad
scientists I give it another pet then
head on my way the Slime oozes off in
the opposite direction I have to find
more new friends I imagine I had no idea
there was anything nice in here with
everything horrible I've seen today once
my cold heart just a little bit it's
strange been walking for a while and I
haven't seen anyone else it's eerily
quiet over here I can I can't hear a
thing except for that alarm in the
distance not sure when all the screaming
went quieter where all the gods went
it's peaceful but I have to admit a
theory there's no way it's this easy
there's no way I'll just be able to walk
out of here life doesn't work like that
especially not here my eyes dot around
watching for any potential danger as I
go maybe all the action is on the other
side of facility maybe something broke
out of containment that's so big so
dangerous that all hands are on Deck to
contain it well maybe they're all dead
and I'm next nah nah I I shouldn't think
like that I feel the hairs on the back
of my neck prickle and I have that
paranoid feeling of being watched like
eyes burning into me I glance behind me
but there's no one there I stopped
walking but I don't hear any other
footsteps calm down there's no one here
with you I tell myself just keep moving
I turn my eyes back to the path ahead of
me and I freeze what was that I saw
something just for a second something
Longs thin spindly like a stick bug but
much much bigger but I look for it it's
gone but I know that I saw it well this
place has now driven me insane glance to
the side of there is again for a split
second so fast I could almost convince
myself I imagined it if I were at home
or walking down an ordinary Street I
might think I I had but I'm not anywhere
ordinary in a slender monster that can
hide my peripheral vision only to be
spotted from millisecond at a time that
seems par for the course in a place like
this there I just saw it again it's like
wants me to know it's here but that'll
I'll never be able to pin it down I'm
not playing mind games with the monster
forget it I'll keep moving another flash
of the creatures closer than it was
before whatever you don't scare me I say
out loud I'm lying but I hope it can't
tell if I just play it cool maybe this
thing will get bored and find someone
else to miss I've been running for a
long time now but my heart is still
pounding I can taste metal the back of
my throat suddenly all the sounds from
before I back the gunfire the screen and
the shriek of alarms made my way back to
the action one sound drowns Out All the
Rest a deafening raw animalistic and
powerful and hateful it reminds me of a
dinosaur in a movie but with the power
that makes my bones Rattle and my teeth
chatter the roar is followed by more
screaming in a massive crash the crunch
of wood and stone is another raw more
distant than before wait whatever made
that sound it just broke out I better
left a pretty big hole in its wake I
follow the sound and find exactly what I
hope I would a massive opening in the
wall and the sweet feeling of a breeze
coming through I couldn't find the next
but this thing just made one for me
always saying more time I make a great
for it dancing around rubble and pools
of corrosive acid and sprinting into the
nearby Forest ducking under branches
done around trees and I run until I'm
seeing spots in my lungs I gasping for
air I don't know how far I'll make it if
there's a town nearby or any kind of
shelter but I promise one thing if I
survive I'm gonna be a better person
I'll get it right this time I'll earn my
second chance at life
scp-682 had escaped containment and it
was all hands on deck at the SCP
Foundation to try and stop the
creature's Rampage all unarmed Personnel
were running to escape before 682 had a
chance to rip them apart as the security
team bravely fought to incapacitate the
hard to destroy reptile long enough to
return him to his acid tank 682 was on
an all-out offensive stomping through
the scp's item gallery and spewing acid
at anyone who came within range people
items and parts of the room alike were
melting and sizzling as 682 attacked it
was an absolute bloodbath and you'd have
to be insane to try and fight back
against it however one being remained
unfazed by the chaos and stood proud in
the face of the omnicidal monster it was
another SCP one who had broken free from
its glass display case in the commotion
potassium
p682 stopped to see who had threatened
him it was almost laughable that this
thing had dared to make such a violent
threat because there was no way that
this little thing would be able to stand
up to the unkillable 682 but its size
didn't stop it from trying to pick a
fight all the same the SCP was a tiny
robot made from junk which looked more
like a sculpture made from scrap that
was found on the side of the road than a
functional automaton it said was made of
an upside down voltmeter giving it the
appearance of a smiling face and its
arms were made of wrenches it was
capable of walking around though it
seemed to have difficulty moving as it
was very top-heavy it shook a rusty fist
at scp-682 and continued to threaten him
shouting you do not know the fury you
have unleashed robo-lord the destructor
will end you as cp682 swiped at the
robot annoyed by its continued attempts
to antagonize him the robot toppled over
and struggled to stand again but when it
did it ran for 682's feet it started to
grab at 682's toes hitting them with its
wrench hands as you might expect this
had almost no effect on 682 you do
realize you are weak pathetic said 682
raising his claw to get a better look at
the annoying little robot it responded
lies and slander the mayor of Mayhem is
the most powerful being in existence
before promptly losing its grip on 682's
claw and falling to the floor now 682
was really getting tired of this thing
he prepared to swipe at it again this
time using his full strength which would
certainly smash the robot to Pieces but
luckily for the robot its pestering had
distracted 682 just long enough for the
foundation's security to sneak up on him
before 682 had a chance to smash the
robot the foundation fired on him with a
volley of rockets reducing him to a
misshapen lump the security team
collected up 682's remains ready to put
them back into a backup acid tank but
the task was made slightly more
difficult by the fact that the robot was
running around underfoot trying in vain
to now attack them instead what was this
strange little robot that thought it
could attack the unkillable lizard 682
meet
scp-1370 appropriately nicknamed the
pesterbot by Foundation Personnel
pesterbot is a small robot made of junk
that displays sentience and the ability
to move despite having no power source
everything about
scp-1370 defies Common Sense the
voltmeter that serves as its head
contains no sensors but it seems unable
to see if the voltmeter is covered its
arms and legs are made of wrenches and
its wooden torso contains a speaker
which it communicates through a tinny
monotone voice pesterbot lives in SCP
Gallery 27 in a glass display case which
is 125 centimeters tall 50 centimeters
wide and 75 centimeters long level 2
personnel and higher are allowed to
remove the robot from containment at
their discretion but penalties will be
incurred for anyone who doesn't return
it to its case due to its impractical
top-heavy Design pesterbot Falls over
frequently when it walks around this led
the foundation to believe that he was
created as an art project and was later
somehow imbued with anomalous properties
rather than being made with the intent
of being sentient pesterbot has
demonstrated at a high capacity for
learning having been taught how to speak
in English French and Latin however the
major factor hampering attempts to
further test its intelligence has
nothing to do with its robotic
processing power no it's because of its
poor attitude pesterbot's encounter with
scp-682 and the Cockiness it expressed
in the moment wasn't an aberration this
SCP really believes it's a killing
machine and as a result it will pick a
fight with anyone and anything that
moves this even includes its own
reflection and as a result the glass of
its contain must be made as
non-reflective as possible to prevent
the robot from damaging the case or
itself and attempts to fight its mirror
self though it's most commonly used
nickname in the foundation is pesterbot
scp-1370 also goes by a variety of
self-given epithets including doombot
2000 Robo Lord the destructor and Darth
claw kill Flex it can be made to add new
names to this list through encouragement
by staff and one time they even managed
to add the name pesterbot as well as the
even more ridiculous patheticon the
gargle most to its lexicon of names as
you may have surmised pesterbot is
classified as safe and is treated by
most SCP Foundation employees is a
humorous Oddity rather than a legitimate
threat many tests have been done on
pesterbot and they've all conclusively
determined that the robot is incapable
of inflicting any damage to its
opponents in fact pesterbot is more a
danger to itself than to anything around
it both because it's incredibly clumsy
and awkward and because it frequently
picks fights with other scps who are far
more powerful than it one such scenario
that could have gone far worse for
pesterbot than it did was its encounter
with
scp-846 also known as Robo dude one of
the many Doctor wondertainment products
currently kept in Foundation containment
Robo dude is an ordinary looking toy
robot that upon request can produce up
to 350 Robo accessories that function as
real weapons Robo dude can deploy
everything from a rocket launcher to a
flamethrower to a gun that shoots out an
unknown species of insect that can chew
through wood however Robo dude seems to
not be sentient and is unable to use
these weapons unless asked to that
ultimately worked out in the favor of
pesterbot during another
scp-682 escape the two robots were
brought into contact as they both had
been broken out of their respective
containment spaces during the brouhaha
robodude searching for a robo pal to
play with Came Upon pester who
immediately started spouting its usual
over-dramatic threats I am the crush
Master doomed to all I survey pesterbot
said gaze upon my might and weep
identify yourself that I might know
whose destruction I shall sow robodude
not programmed to know how to respond to
such a statement simply responded by
asking pester mod if it wanted to play
pesterbot continued to Trash Talk Robo
dude until Robo dude decided the best
way to play with its new pal was to
engage it in its robot dance mode
pesterbot accepted the challenge saying
activate all that you wish but your fate
is sealed the kilotron cannot be
defeated I shall render you unto dust
with my mad dancing skills the two
robots proceeded to engage in a dance
battle which the awkwardly shaped Pastor
bot failed miserably at while Robo dude
was a competent dancer Pastor bot could
only gyrate pathetically before it fell
over and rolled around the ground
hopelessly out of time to the music
coming from robodude speakers the song
ended and Robo do declared Robo dance is
complete Robo Powell pesterbot was
unable to accept its failure and replied
ha pathetic one you have been schooled
in the art of the dance by none other
than the meccano Basher scourge of a
thousand worlds kneel before me before I
end your worthless existence Robo dude
unimpressed with pesterbot's poor
sportsmanship deployed its hydrogen
Cannon which it was programmed to do
whenever it detected a sore loser
fortunately for pesterbot hydrogen
Cannon was just the name for robo dude's
water pistol while pesterbot will
attempt to fight anything that moves the
truth is this robot will attack
virtually anything it perceives as being
even slightly alive this is perhaps best
illustrated by one of the tests of
pesterbot's abilities that involve
putting a small speaker at the base of a
potted houseplant and speaking through
it from another room the plant was
placed across from pesterbot in the
testing chamber and the interaction was
monitored by researchers from outside
researcher Davey spoke through the
speaker in the plant on he asked
pesterbot if he could hear him and it
answered Who Dares All Souls will burn
you will feel the sharp sting of my
wrath identify yourself so that I may
sing damnation upon you as you die the
robot began approaching the plant Davies
speaking as the plan identified himself
I'm a split leaf philodendron a
semi-woody shrub with large glossy
leaves at this point he had to try very
hard not to laugh at the absurdity of
this test and the robot's reaction he
continued these leaves can grow up to
three feet long pesterbotta used its
wrench to try and wrestle with the
leaves but was bested by the mighty
plant and unable to cause any damage
enraged by its failure it said your
mockery spousyard Dome I have arrived
you will be crushed betwixt my digits
pesterbot then fell over and was unable
to write itself it struggled and spent
six minutes trying to stand before its
flailing knocked over the plant which
did nothing to help and in fact pinned
the robot to the ground it was at this
point that the researchers who had taken
time to compose themselves after several
laughing fits enter the chamber and
remove pesterbot in order to place it
back in its containment case despite how
non-threatening pesterbot is there is
actually one situation in the
foundation's history where it actually
posed a somewhat serious threat when
mobile task forces were sent in to
rescue survivors of the events at site
13 also known as
scp-1730 they were attacked by alternate
universe versions of a variety of
creatures kept in Foundation containment
one of these creatures was pesterbot who
in that Universe somehow gained control
of a larger mechanical body constructed
of discarded pieces of Machinery it
threw other pieces of metal scrap at the
task force as they tried to leave the
site shouting in a much deeper and more
intimidating voice I am reborn to
breathe Devastation upon this fetid
Earth pitiful humans you will feel the
dark sting of my never-ending torment
members of the task force could see the
original pesterbot body on top of the
larger metal construct waving its arms
madly the task force opened fire to
little effect pesterbot tossed another
piece of scrap at them just narrowly
missing one Task Force member threw a
frag grenade at the robot which it
caught blowing up its hand another one
was able to jump into the air and reach
the tiny robot atop the larger body
knocking it against the wall and
shattering it even in the reality where
pestrobot was able to build itself a
larger body it still ultimately wasn't
able to put up that much of a fight poor
Pastor bot doomed to be a failure in
this and apparently every other reality
that's the story of scp-1370 also known
as pesterbot one of the most hilariously
harmless anomalous entities that the
foundation currently has in containment
perhaps one day he'll achieve his goal
of Conquering the universe he just has
to figure out how to conquer his toy box
first hello again dear viewers you
caught me during my break but even
researchers at the SCP Foundation need a
little down time now and then and
considering they revoked my playtime
privileges with the living Lego and the
nerfing gun after that unfortunate
incident in the site-19 break room I've
been downgraded to keeping myself
occupied with this little rubber ball I
have a ball perhaps you'd like to bounce
it they say seems innocent enough
doesn't it
[Laughter]
have you learned nothing almost any
object even something as innocuous as a
teddy bear or a plastic paddling pool
can hide Secrets sure any Avid
basketball fan will happily tell you
that ball is life but sometimes when
you're dealing with anomalies a ball can
also be death such is the case of
scp-018 also known as the Super Ball an
anomaly so powerful that the foundation
has even used it to help recontain
scp-682 during a breach to the untrained
Observer it really isn't much to look at
a small Red Rubber Ball around six
centimeters in diameter produced by the
wamo company in 1969. yeah we were as
surprised as you to find out that good
old doctor wondertainment had nothing to
do with this little number you might
also be surprised by just how extensive
the containment procedures are for
scp-018 after all it's rare that a
completely non-sentient anomaly makes
its way into the Euclid class this
little rubber ball is kept in a
specially made titanium alloy metal
restraint submerged in a dense
polyethylene holding tank filled with a
special endothermic compound that draws
the kinetic energy out of its
surroundings anyone entering the chamber
needs to wear a unique kind of
reinforced plate armor and if scp-018
ever manages to escape its containment
tank nearby Personnel are advised to
treat it as they would an active shooter
situation lock yourself in a nearby room
duck down below any cover you can find
and wait for armed containment units to
show up and take control of the
situation at this point you probably
have a lot of questions Chief among them
being why is this children's toy being
given more security precautions than
most serial killers the ball was first
discovered when a cleaning and Disposal
Company was hired to empty out an old
wamo Warehouse of some defunct
merchandise one of the movers Roy
Fishler embraced his inner child when he
saw a Red Rubber Ball sitting among all
the dusty boxes of expired Silly Putty
and broken remote control robots he
thought to himself ah what's the harm in
having a little fun here it's all going
in the trash anyway this would prove to
be a terrible mistake for all involved
the anomalous property of scp-018 is the
fact that it's able to bounce at 200
percent efficiency every time it's
bounced increasing at an exponential
rate with each bounce unless it's
stopped by some equivalent Force so when
Roy decided to toss that little red ball
onto the ground he Unleashed a
destructive force into that warehouse
that was more powerful than he could
ever have imagined with every bounce the
ball increased its height and speed
ricocheting across the floor walls and
ceiling like a bullet run amok and it
was only just getting started the
workers hit the deck as the item that
would later be dubbed scp-018 decided to
put the ball in ballistic it smashed
light fixtures knocked over piles of
boxes smashed through forklifts when one
worker tried to catch it it left a red
hot ball-shaped hole in the middle of
his palm it wasn't long before the ball
had built up such speed that the
warehouse could no longer contain it it
blasted out of the wall and rocketed
into a nearby City ready to cause more
abject chaos wherever it went windows
were shattered street lights were
annihilated cars crashed thankfully no
humans were killed by the rampaging
rubber Menace but in total five people
were injured and one unfortunate pigeon
was utterly obliterated on impact it
went on for several days with the ball
reaching over 100 kilometers per hour at
several points before finally coming to
a rest at a nearby lake at which point
it was retrieved by Foundation personnel
there were two silver linings to this
incredibly strange anomalous incident
the first was as previously alluded to
nobody actually died the second was that
due to the incredible speeds at which
scp-018 moved none of the civilian
Witnesses had any idea what they just
encountered as far as anomalous
discoveries go this was pretty much as
close to a win as you can get but for
one ambitious researcher it was far more
than just a pleasingly non-violent
initial containment story it was a
doorway to improving the foundation's
technology as a whole meet Dr Brian
carella he's what you might call a
Maverick Blue Sky thinker always on his
grind the Cornerstone of Dr corella's
philosophy was that the foundation
should be making more active use of its
benign anomalies to help track down and
contain their more ornery foes while
everyone else around him seemed to only
see a little rubber nuisance that was
better locked away Dr Corella saw the
immense potential in scp-018 namely in
providing a vital enhancement to another
piece of Foundation Technology the
scp-a5 armor it goes without saying that
working for the SCP Foundation is an
incredibly dangerous job especially if
you're part of one of the found nation's
Myriad of mobile task forces the hunt
for anomalies can lead to all kinds of
strange and inhospitable terrains before
it was contained scp-096 was famously
captured on an icy frozen tundra on top
of a bleak Mountain because of incidents
like this the foundation had first
invested money in the scp-85 Tactical
armor suit think of them like the
foundation's answer to the Iron Man suit
however when dressed in several hundred
pounds of reinforced metal something
important suffers along the way Mobility
it isn't exactly easy to Lug all that
equipment around and when an anomaly is
heading for the hills at high speeds
being well defended doesn't count for
much if you're already 10 miles behind
the Target in Pursuit this in Dr
corella's mind was exactly where scp-018
came into play if that little red ball
was built into the foot of an scp-85
armor suit it could be used to bounce
the operative wearing it to tremendous
Heights this would allow them to not
only give Chase against fast-moving
anomalies but also cover difficult
terrain and even scale Great Heights in
a mere instant but it wasn't just an
increase to Mobility that scp-018
integration offered to the scp-a5 suit
picture this with scp-018 fuse to the
sole of the suit's reinforced metal foot
lending a 200 bouncing efficiency it
could unleash a deadly concrete
shattering kick the kind of thing that
would leave you singing a falsetto for
the rest of your life if you were lucky
enough to survive it if you know what I
mean to Dr Corella it was a match made
in heaven it could increase both the
mobility and combat effectiveness of the
suits by a considerable margin and
seeing as scp-018 literally didn't have
a mind of its own there was no way it
could suddenly go Rogue during a mission
and compromise everything just as able
had done during his stint as a mobile
task force operator before they ran out
of targets for him and he started
slaughtering his own comrades Dr Corella
was so confident in the efficacy of this
idea he contacted the o5 council
personally to request approval for this
little pet project this approval was
granted on a purely experimental basis
the technology would have to prove
itself before being put into common use
it wasn't exactly what Corella wanted to
hear but it was a step in the right
direction he just needed the perfect
opportunity to put them to the test and
then it came
scp-682 the infamous hard to destroy
reptile breach containment it somehow
adapted a cloaking ability and escaped
further from the site it was being held
at than ever before the next time it was
spotted was over two weeks later causing
pandemonium in the Amazon rainforest
devouring tribesmen and Wrecking havoc
on the local ecosystem they needed to
get on the scene fast and put that
monster down before the damage it caused
was irreparable and news of the beast in
the Amazon leaked out into the local
area and thankfully Dr had just the tool
for the job field agent Hammersmith was
fitted with an scp-85 suit complete with
the scp-018 enhancement in his dominant
right leg he was dispatched and
immediately the augmented suit began to
show its efficacy agent Hammersmith
bounded above the tree line at
incredible speeds using the HUD in The
suit's Mask to track the heat signature
of scp-682 moving among the trees below
him he'd been able to bind a tracking
collar to the beast's neck during an
earlier engagement but now the true
battle was on his heart was pounding
adrenaline coursing through his veins
but he'd been ensured that even 682
would have a hard time tearing through
his suit's armor a commander directing
him through an earpiece told him that
now was the time to engage before 682
detected his presence and began
developing countermeasures Dr Corella
was watching a live feed from the
control room confident that his 018
augmented suit would do the job
following his orders to the letter
Hammersmith descended down onto 682 from
above however before he could make
contact the reptile swiped him with its
tail sending his body sailing into a
nearby tree however the suit stood firm
he felt the impact but the actual damage
was minimal now it was time for him to
face off against the Beast one-on-one he
didn't have time to be afraid as the
Beast descended upon Him fangs Baird he
gave it a swift kick to the bottom jaw
tearing off half of its face but anyone
who knows scp-682 would tell you that
simply removing its bottom jaw wouldn't
even slow 682 down it was relentless
attacking Hammersmith with its fangs and
Jaws it tore deep ruts into the suit's
metal but the suit was still managing to
keep its occupants safe then Hammersmith
struck back kick after kick augmented by
the 200 power of the Super Ball slicing
huge chunks from the reptile's body he
kicked in its chest kicked off its Limbs
and with a final Mighty kick he even
managed to bisect the beast in the
middle of course even that wouldn't keep
it down for long but with the hum of
evacuation and containment helicopters
rapidly approaching Hammersmith breathed
a sigh of relief back in the control
room everyone celebrated Dr Corella most
of all Vindicated in this belief that
scp-018 could save the day and then
agent Hammersmith without even thinking
rested his right foot on the floor just
that little bit too firmly the sunbounce
set Hammersmith a mile into the air his
foundation-trained composure evaporated
all he could do was scream as he blasted
up into the clouds then began to plummet
back in the control room everyone could
see a live feed of agent Hammersmith
hurtling into a nearby lake and Landing
with an epic Splash while the
regenerating remains of scp-682 were
contained and brought back into the
nearest containment site another team
was sent in to retrieve the heavily
injured agent Hammersmith his medical
examination afterwards revealed that
he'd suffered two broken legs seven
broken ribs a missing arm and a skull
fracture if he hadn't been wearing that
suit his mangled remains probably would
have been devoured by the local piranhas
by now but despite that minor hiccup in
the plan Dr Corella was still delighted
with the results and immensely proud of
the little red ball that could in his
closing remarks on the incident he
appended a final note to the scp-018
file reading don't worry it's fixed but
I have some more ideas if I can be
granted the use of some water from
scp-006 as well as some other scps I can
deliver you a set of scp-a5 armor and an
agent that can capture any if not all
Rogue or unattained scps all I'm waiting
on is your approval welcome to planet
Earth she's got the toughest streets
around and if you're not careful that
mean old Missy won't hesitate to wash
out her gutters with your blood and
decorate the sidewalks with your teeth
it's a tough world for the good and
innocent with the looming Shadow Of
Crime lurking around every corner just
waiting to prey on those who are unable
to defend themselves if you don't have
the tools to survive it'll chew you up
and spit you out like a wad of stale
chewing gum that's why we need a hero a
dark Defender a cloak in the night we
need the Specter New Delhi India a woman
walks home from her late night job she's
exhausted she can feel the bone deep
ache of 14 hours on a factory Line
running herself ragged to support her
three kids back home she can barely
stand can you really blame her for
wanting to take the shortcut down that
dark alley knowing it'll shave 15
minutes off her trip she ducks in
clutching her purse tight and keeping
her head down but it won't do any good a
predator has been lying in weight he
emerges from the darkness wielding a
huge
and grabs her by the shoulder he's a few
heads taller than her with arms thicker
than her neck he tells her to hand over
the money she'd spent all month working
for or he'd turn her kids into orphans
his knife had tasted blood before and
he'd have no problem killing again with
tears streaking down her face knowing
it's futile to resist she reaches out
and passes him the money the Bandit
snatches it from her trembling hand and
Snickers candy from a baby he's ready to
turn around and make a run with
tonight's takings when he feels an odd
chill drift into the alley a soft whoosh
he turns and sees a figure standing and
watching him he's tall and well built
with a long black coat and a wide
brimmed hat he was darker than the dark
light seemed to disappear into him a
black shape against the background it's
him the man that all criminals know and
fear all over the world even if they've
never met him the intrusive thought the
moment of creeping doubt that slithers
into their minds the second they even
contemplate breaking the law the bad
guys Boogeyman the Specter halt evildoer
the Specter commands you'll return this
fine lady's money or you'll suffer the
consequences the Bandit feels the Tremor
of fear quiver through him but he won't
back down not yet he charges the Specter
with this blade slashing like a madman
but not a single hit lands the Specter
weaves perfectly away from every strike
and effortlessly disarms the Bandit with
a perfectly placed whack to the wrist
the knife clatters to the ground he
discombobulates the Bandit with an open
Palm strike to either side of his head
then knocks him out with a laser focused
headbutt he crumples to the ground
unconscious and the Specter breathes a
sigh another battle one this whole time
the woman has been watching Frozen and
awe the Specter picks up her stolen
money and hands it back to her with a
gentlemanly doff of his wide-brimmed hat
he really is just darkness underneath
unseeable a unknowable a living Shadow
she thanks him and he assures her that
it's all in a day's work for a crime
fighter like him after all somebody
needs to do it and in a flash of smoke
he's gone the woman makes it home safely
that night London England a man lays
beaten and bloody On The Ground Three
assailants surround him circling like
hungry wolves one wields a long lead
pipe still slick with the man's blood
another a switchblade that he keeps
clicking in and out of the handle and
the third carries a handgun the same
handgun he's used to take two lives
before the wounded man on the ground
with bruises cuts a broken ankle a
broken wrist four broken ribs and three
missing teeth is desperate and afraid
he's here because he was forced into a
corner he needed to borrow money from a
dangerous man tucked away in a dingy
building in London's East End the city's
organized crime epicenter the money he'd
borrow came with predatory interest that
he couldn't pay back now he's paying the
difference in blood to that same lone
shark's violent goons the man with a gun
in a thick Cockney accent tells him that
this is why he shouldn't have messed
around with Mr Ford now he's going to be
an example for anyone else stupid enough
to think they can stiff the Big Man on a
payment and live to tell the tale he
nods to the man with the pipe to finish
the job the beaten and bloodied man on
the ground closes his eyes as the Goon
steps closer lifting up the red stained
pipe and preparing to finally cave his
pitiful head in with it in the dark he
hears the whoosh of the pipes downswing
and the breeze hits his bruised cheek
but the pipe never connects instead
there's a chorus of gasps the man on the
ground opens his eyes to get a better
look at what on Earth has happened a
tall dark man in a long black coat and a
wide brimmed hat is standing over him
holding the lead pipe that he just
easily snatched from the hands of his
previous user the goons are all stepping
back the gunman raises his pistol the
other his knife all of them look afraid
the man on the ground doesn't know the
stranger who just saved his life but in
his presence he feels something wash
over him that he hasn't felt in a long
while safety it's him it's the Specter
you wretched villains do you know better
than to pick on the weak a bunch of
tough guys like you how about fighting
someone your own size in a blind panic
the gunman raises his pistol and fires
the Specter moves like smoke in the wind
he Dodges the bullet and tosses the lead
pipe it sails through the air and hits
the gunman's skull with An Almighty
crack he collapses dropping his weapon
the other two goons bum rush him but it
doesn't serve them any better one
slashes the other punches with a few
skillful fluid movements he guides one
goon's knife-wielding hand into the
other shoulder then disables both with a
pair of simultaneous chops to the throat
like that Jackie Chan himself would be
proud of all Three Goons are laid out on
the ground either writhing and gasping
or knocked out cold the Specter
straightens his coat and hat with
practice finesse and returns to the man
laying on the ground after checking that
he was still alive and conscious he
passed the man a wad of cash and a phone
telling him to call an ambulance and get
his wounds treated none of those men
would ever bother him again and if they
or any others dared to then they could
expect to see the dark figure of the
Specter appearing behind them in their
bathroom mirror after all someone needs
to be there to fight crime even when
nobody else will New York City USA
things are going sideways at a major
Bank downtown a group of well-armed
highly organized robbers has broken in
they've taken at least 50 hostages
throughout the building and have
informed the police blockade outside
that unless their demands are met and
they're given free passage out of the
building they'll start executing people
left and right and given the ruthless
organization of this particular criminal
crew it seems more than likely that
they'll put their blood Money where
their mouth is police squad cars form a
horseshoe blockade around the building
outside armed with handguns shotguns and
assault rifles police snipers are
finding their ideal perches in the
surrounding skyscrapers SWAT is on the
way in a police helicopter circles above
however even if everything goes right
the higher-ups know that some fatalities
are basically inevitable Crews of
Hardcore career criminals like this
wouldn't go down without a fight one way
or another some lives would be taken
today another transmission is delivered
from the inside after that the robbers
know that time isn't on their side so
their flipping the script five minutes
exactly if their demands aren't met by
then blood would be staining the bank's
Immaculate marble floor Tick Tock the
negotiators on the front line are in a
cold sweat five minutes no that isn't
enough time we can't mobilize it'll be a
massacre in there how could 10 greedy
Maniacs with assault rifles pull the rug
out from under them all like this Panic
thoughts swim through the head of a
sergeant heading the blockade he can't
concede his superiors would never allow
it does he wait five minutes and see
what happens or authorizes officers to
breach the front doors try to reclaim
the bank and potentially create one of
the worst bank robbery bloodbaths in New
York City history damned if he does
damned if he doesn't and every second
the time to decide runs out that's when
he hears a soft whoosh behind him
paranoid enough to jump at Shadows the
sergeant turns reaching for his gun and
sees what seems to be a Dapper's Shadow
standing right behind him a tall man
with a long black coat and a wide
brimmed hat no face just darkness itself
under the shade of the brim The Stranger
places a calm hand on his shoulder and
suddenly a sense of trust like he hasn't
felt in years just sets in somehow deep
in his marrow he knows that this man is
here to help rest assured Sergeant
everything is under control now for I
the Specter have arrived to save the day
how many criminals are inside the
sergeant murmurs Den in awe the Specter
nods worry not Sergeant nobody will die
today and with that like the ghost that
is his very namesake the Specter is gone
inside the bank the leader of the
robbers checks his watch two minutes and
still no word from the cops outside he's
starting to lose his patience a few
unfortunate bank tellers and customers
Crouch around him their hands behind
their heads five of his men are out here
with with him armed in keeping the
situation under control the other four
have cracked the security on the Vault
and they're hauling out money by the bag
full and still Silence from the cops he
sneers and the thought crosses his mind
that perhaps if he takes out a hostage
or two now the moocs out there might
actually take his threat seriously that
thought amuses him yeah that'll show him
they'll finally know who they're dealing
with here the leader shoulders his
assault rifle and draws a bead on the
hostages sitting closest to him even his
men are shocked by the suddenness of it
all but they know better than to
second-guess their boss at a time like
this he was always a little trigger
happy the hostage and older gentleman
who'd only come into the bank to check
his balance cause he hadn't figured out
how to do it online just yet seize the
gun and winces he survived NAMM and this
was how he was going to go gunned down
on a Wednesday afternoon by some creep
for chump change what a world the
leader's finger curls around the trigger
but before he can complete a squeeze an
expertly aimed fist collides with the
back of his head knocking him
unconscious in a single strike the
leader collapses his rifle sliding
across the ground the Specter stands
where he stood straightening his coat
and blowing dandruff off of his knuckles
are you fellas ready to dance he growls
he Glides through them moving with the
grace of a prima ballerina and hitting
with the force of a freight train the
goons are down before any of them can
fire a single shot with the help of some
quick thinking bank tellers the Specter
closes the vault door from the outside
trapping the remaining four robbers
inside textbook crime fighting once more
the bank customers and employees weeping
with joy and relief thanked the Specter
for saving their lives he shakes his
hand and assures them it was nothing
just doing what he could as any
concerned citizen should he would have
left after that were it not for one
little
the NYPD has a number of employees at
different levels of their sprawling
structure that are actually deeply
embedded undercover agents of the SCP
Foundation and this isn't a comic book
there's a word for when a mysterious man
made from Darkness appears from nowhere
and effortlessly takes down 10 heavily
armed highly trained combatants by
himself and that word was anomalous
knowing what this mysterious combatant
was capable of the foundation sends some
of their best mobile task force
operatives to apprehend him under the
guise of just being standard SWAT team
members sent in to get the situation
back under control in the aftermath of
the robbery however much to their
extreme surprise the Specter puts up
absolutely no resistance to them he
understands that the men here to
apprehend him are Servants of Law and
Order and would not defy their well but
he pleads with them to reconsider you
don't understand sirs you're making a
huge mistake he says distraught I'm here
to help I'm the Vector defender of the
innocent scourge of the evildoer you
can't lock me away you can't the people
need me as tragic as it is to see a
genuinely benevolent anomaly beg for his
freedom the mobile task Force's Hearts
have long since hardened to this kind of
thing he wouldn't be the first Sapient
humanoid anomaly to speedrun all seven
stages of grief on their knees in front
of them and he probably wouldn't be the
last Foundation protocol is to tag and
bag either way even if they just use
their anomalous abilities to thwart a
bank robbery the Specter is hauled back
to the nearest Foundation containment
site and held in a holding cell while
researchers prepare to conduct initial
tests and questioning everything seems
so run-of-the-mill little do they notice
something extremely strange is starting
to happen to New York City beyond the
containment Chambers walls they're about
to learn the true devastating
consequences of keeping a pure force of
good like the specter locked up like a
switch has been flipped nearby police
suddenly become oddly listless instead
of working they just chat with each
other and random citizens about the
weather some watch SCP explained on
their phone while active robberies are
happening a man is mugged right in front
of a squad car and the cop inside just
listens to his Van Halen CDs at max
volume in actual precincts the on-duty
cops start to wonder why on Earth
they're actually here in this building
all together listening to phone calls
from weirdly panicked people and typing
up reports on stuff it all just seems
oddly confusing they decide to go
outside and watch clouds or go home and
play video games it doesn't make any
sense that they're just standing around
in here doing nothing for no reason
across the city strange incidents start
to occur people who so much as knock
into each other while walking on the
crowded New York streets begin to brawl
with one another on the ground while
nobody around them even really
acknowledges that they're doing it let
alone tries to break them up nearby cars
crash at the intersection and rather
than getting out to exchange insurance
information The Irate drivers draw guns
and start to duel-like bit characters in
an old cowboy movie nobody really seems
to mind as if noticing a change in the
wind organized crime rackets decide that
secrecy isn't the way to go anymore mob
enforcers Rob stores and shake down
random people in the streets taking
wallets watches phones and jewelry
criminals break into people's homes and
start ransacking the place stealing
everything from flat screen TVs to
Priceless family heirlooms while their
owners sit on the couch seemingly unable
to even comprehend that something is
going wrong here but everything is still
about to get a whole lot worse the city
breaks into riots and looting people
battling in the streets news helicopters
Circle above reporting the chaos
unfolding below them but they do so with
an odd kind of detached calm not really
comprehending the full scope of what's
happening or why just that a whole lot
more is on fire now than it was before
how strange this is the moment when the
SCP Foundation realizes the meaning of
the specters pleading he really was
being entirely unselfish because you see
the Specter isn't just an extremely
devoted crime fighter he's the very
personification of the concept of
fighting crime he can't ever be locked
up or contained because if you do then
the very concept of resisting crime
Fades from the human consciousness order
ceases to be and Chaos Reigns that's why
the Specter also known as scp-4494 is
classified as archon meaning that he
can't be contained because the danger of
containing him would be far greater than
the danger of letting him roam around
and do his thing unhindered he maintains
an amicable relationship with the the
SCP Foundation after everything that
happened willing to swoop in and help
their agents when they're in a bind and
need a little hand from a true hero and
when he's not fighting crime he relaxes
in the Specter cave by watching TV and
playing video games no we're not making
that up unsurprisingly his favorite
video games are the ones where you get
to play as superheroes though he will
occasionally indulge in some Grand Theft
Auto 5. just don't expect him to break
any traffic loss while he's playing
thank you very much so if ever you feel
afraid or if the dark forces that are
all too human in this world are
marshalling against you know this you
don't fight alone there's a man in the
shadows ready to come to your Aid he's a
warrior for justice he's a defender of
the innocent but most of all he is the
Specter oh God oh God I'm trapped in the
infinite Ikea how long have I been in
here can I get out how can I get out how
can I survive the vicious staff of the
infinite Ikea and work with the other
survivors in this terrifying endless
building okay let's start from the
beginning day one I'd come to this flat
pack nightmare with my lovely wife
Brenda to pick up some stupid sofa she
saw online we could have ordered it in
but me being a cheapskate and a fool
instead decided it'd be a Dandy idea to
head in and pick it up ourselves even
though I can't stand shopping in these
giant stores of course it didn't take
long for us to get separated I was
wandering around just pretending I knew
what I was doing surrounded by
unfamiliar people then not surrounded by
any people at all like the complete
doofus I was I'd somehow gotten lost
just needed to find my bearings again
and then I could call Brenda to come
save me but I never did find my bearings
the hours went on and I was still lost
day two my dominant emotion on this day
was nothing more than sheer humiliation
knowing I'd been best in by a damn
Swedish furniture store I spent the
night before sleeping on a futon
wondering how I'd gotten myself into
this flat pack Calamity I spent the day
searching for food my confusion and
exhaustion increasing by the moment for
a while I even entertained the idea that
I might have died and gone to some
Nordic hell at night I went to bed
hungry knowing if I didn't eat soon I
might be found as a skeleton on a Dusty
old futon oh God I came in like this I
can't die on day two day three I
continued my journey through the
Labyrinthian vows of the Ikea
disoriented by the endlessly iterating
collections of cheap furniture you know
there was something terrifying about the
emptiness of it all this affordable but
impossible to assemble void starvation
has always been one of the most horrific
deaths hasn't it you could only imagine
my relief when I saw the figure standing
a few feet in front of me dressed like a
member of Ikea staff I'd found salvation
I found someone who could help me out of
here but when I approached I realized
something was probably wrong this wasn't
a human being standing before me it was
a monster the being I'd later come to
know is called the staff by the many
people who fear them it chased me
repeating their store is closed you need
to vacate the premises flailing for me
with its long frightening limbs I only
survived day three because I locked
myself in a closet and just waited while
it hammered against the wood with its
fists once the night was over it left
and I was able to escape day four
I was feeling some intense hunger pangs
on this day not to mention the fact that
I now knew there were monsters out there
just waiting to beat me to death if they
caught me when the lights turned down
needless to say I wasn't in the best
headspace and I didn't have enough
charge on my phone to justify opening up
my meditation app then I found Nirvana I
found the cafeteria stocked full of
delicious warm Swedish meatballs you
know no food has ever tasted so sweet to
me then this delicious meal also gave
way to one of the most exciting new
developments Gloria Gloria was a veteran
she taught me everything I needed to
know about this place even on the first
day I met her she felt like someone I'd
known for years it was her that took me
back to her home in this place a little
Fortress made of Ikea furniture filled
with a whole community of other people
trapped in there it was like being
allowed into the Garden of Eden day five
and it feels good to be alive I met up
with all the different people around the
camp they tell me the most bizarre and
fascinating stories this sounds crazy I
know but I get the sense not all of them
came from the same place as me different
Ikeas in different countries or maybe
even as nutty as it sounds from
different worlds one guy Tony who's been
trapped in here for a year and some
change and we got to talking about
different vacations we take it on the
outside he told me he was from New York
and I told him I visited there once and
I'd love going to see the Statue of
Liberty up close that's when he told me
that he'd never heard of the Statue of
Liberty you know I didn't know what to
make
strange little details aside I couldn't
be happier to be there with other people
The Next Step would be finding a way out
of here and back to Brenda day six
Gloria and several others led me out on
our first Excursion missions where the
goal was to collect more food and
supplies and map out the surrounding
area I nearly jumped out of my skin when
I saw a staff member standing in our
path at one point and the others all
just laughed at me staff member just
stood there Placid and still Gloria told
me that it's okay the staff are harmless
during the day it's only night time when
they enter their pattern of aggression
so long as you don't get lost during the
daytime you're generally fine the team
often use string like thesis to trail
behind them and ensure they don't get
lost it was clear they'd been here long
enough to work out systems for every
possibility felt like I was in good
hands with him we collected meatballs
and some rugs to fortify the walls and
headed back the A7 this was the first
night that we had to defend off a
full-on attack those monsters the staff
came at us in huge groups pounding at
the outside of our perimeter with their
bulb fists it was terrifying as we were
fighting them off we tied Ikea kitchen
knives to the end of curtain rails and
speared them one by one until all of
them were dead they
are coming more and more and more of
them but it looked like one of the walls
to the north of the community was going
to fall everyone around me started to
panic that's when Barry one of the
biggest men in the camp grabbed a hammer
in each hand and went outside and fought
like a beast taking on staff member
after staff member tanking hit after hit
it was something to see that's when he
took off into the depths of the store
drawing the staff away behind him and
saving us all we never saw Barry again
after that but he's the reason all of us
made it past day seven thank you Barry
wherever you are day eight Gloria took
me out alone today on another search for
the Escape that's when she told me about
her sister she'd gone shopping in Ikea
with her well over a year ago now when
she was separated and got lost in here
just like me I had a lot in common with
her including my feelings of guilt for
abandoning my loved ones and my drive to
escape and be United with them while we
were out that day we didn't find
anything useful Gloria seems sad but
unsurprised the infinite Ikea had its
way of slowly grinding you down days 9
today 17. despite a rocky start I was
finding my legs in the infinite Ikea I
started to get to know my fellow Ikea
prisoners I started to understand and
truly befriend them we went on
Expeditions pretty much daily either to
collect new food more supplies to help
build up our community or to keep
searching for an exit to me it started
to feel like we were making progress and
that helped a great deal to keep my
emotions semi-stable but it wasn't the
same for Gloria after all she'd been
here for so much longer than me and she
added her sister to consider on the
outside to her these routines I was
becoming part of now felt like a prison
within a prison she was trapped had her
sister forgotten her out there had she
been declared dead or people even still
looking for her and it was on day 18
that it all got a little too much for
poor Gloria she snuck out of the camp at
night and the staff were most active
trying to find the exit sadly that had
cost Gloria her life there's no way of
knowing happened to her exactly but
considering how bruised up her body was
when we found her it was easy to make an
educated guess she'd gotten bum rushed
by the staff and beaten to death before
she could have even mustered up a
defense it was a horrible way to go we
tried giving her a dignified funeral as
we could given the circumstances buzzing
her up in a body-sized box that was the
day I decided to stop just trying to
survive and start trying to escape I owe
that to Brenda if she really had gotten
out I couldn't keep her waiting but I
wouldn't be alone as it turns out
another two members of the little Ikea
Community I'd come to know were willing
to risk it all with me a man named
Kelvin and a young woman named Vicki
they were sick of just waiting around
and fending off attacks from the staff
night after night they both told me
they'd rather die during an escape
attempt than while cowering under a pile
of cheap rugs and so each armed with
claw hammers from the six-piece Ikea fix
a tool kit and as many proved that
Tupperware containers full of Meatballs
that we could carry we set off into the
great unknown of Ikea we traveled for
weeks marking our tracks on the ground
with the Mala mixed colors chalk
selection so we never got caught going
in circles one day bled into the next
nights were spent trying to hide in
closets and bathtubs while the staff
hunted relentlessly for people just like
us every single time we got lucky that
is until day 41. here's something you
need to know about the infinite Ikea
you're probably already aware if you're
watching this that the 24-hour cycle of
night and day is dictated by the store
lights up above but the space between
day and night isn't a gradient here it's
a Cliff you can be minding your own
business when suddenly hitch darkness
and now the staff are on your ass that's
exactly what happened on day 41. we're
in the middle of a kitchenware selection
surrounded by a few docile members of
Staff when suddenly the light switched
off and they went hostile on us they
look pretty goofy after the initial
shock is worn off but believe me when I
say that these monsters can really pack
a mean Wallop when they want to and we
received a reminder of this unfortunate
fact that night the staff swarmed us
repeating that awful phrase the store is
closed do you need to vacate the
premises while they struck and flailed
at us if it wasn't for our trusty claw
hammers we would have been dead that
night thankfully we were able to give
better than we were getting we managed
to kill a decent number of Staff members
and then make a run for a section with
better hiding places myself Vicki and
Calvin all stowed away in a large
wardrobe until we saw light flickering
through the crack in the door like we
were rejected extras for some painful
Community Theater take on Chronicles of
Narnia but Huawei survived that night we
didn't survive unscathed my face was
swollen from a nasty punch one of the
staff members stealped me and from the
pain in my chest I might have been
dealing with a few broken ribs Kelvin
sprained his ankle during the escape and
Vicky had a cut on her forehead from
when one of the staff members knead her
in the face during The Fray he never win
these fights he just survived them we
made a temporary camp in the area where
we could rest and recover as well as
shaking off the justifiable fear of
death or Grievous harm that dampened our
resolve to get out of this place that
took us to day 53. of course food was
always a concern I don't want to
romanticize what happened in there as
much as I'm sure someone on the outside
might want to imagine this whole
experience as some kind of exciting
survival horror game but I assure you it
was less survival horror and more
survival and horror meaning not only are
we suffering from constant fear stress
and paranoia for our safety in here but
we also need to keep ourselves fed and
watered you're just as likely to die
from starvation and here as you are to
be beaten to death we went in search of
another Ikea kitchen where we could fill
up on more water and meatballs your
lifeblood in a place like this it took
us several more days of searching and
hiding searching and hiding before we
hit Pay Dirt by the time we actually got
our hands on the food and water we were
starving and practically coughing up
dust those meatballs were the most
delicious food I've ever tasted and I
could tell from their faces that Calvin
and Vicki felt exactly the same way
though at the moment I told myself if no
when I get out of here I never eat
another meatball it'd probably give me
war flashbacks or I guess store
flashbacks we filled up our Tupperware
and shoved them back into our Kia
proving backpacks then we needed to keep
moving keep searching and keep marking
the ground behind us as we fanned out
into the great flat pack Yonder avoiding
confrontations wherever we could the
three of us still had no idea what
Insanity was waiting for us out there we
had no idea that there were even more
dangerous things than the staff lurking
in the shadows day 68. of course I kept
count writing it down on the back of my
jet lick coloring book trust me when
every night could mean a horrible death
you keep track of the
not a single one of them escapes you at
a certain point I think we all adapted
in our own way it was back to caveman
times again learning to be like our
Primal ancestors hiding away from the
dark and the monsters that hid there so
it was extremely surprising for us to
get the most brutal attack during the
day at first I thought we were being
attacked by the staff during daylight
hours like a bolt from the blue that's
when we noticed they weren't attacking
with their hands they were all holding
kitchen knives holding us up like
Bandits that's when we realized what
actually happened here we weren't being
attacked by the staff we were being
attacked by other humans dressed like
the staff wearing their hollowed-out
heads like grisly masks they told us
that we were coming with them and if we
resisted they'd cut us to ribbons and
seeing as none of us were movie action
heroes we thought it'd be best to do
exactly what they said this is how we
fell into the clutches of generalissimo
vardagen day 69
things were not nice I mean I get it
yeah haha funny nice I don't know if I'd
mentioned this before but the community
I became part of in the infinite Ikea
after meeting Gloria was just one of
many nobody knows exactly how many
people are trapped in here I'm hardly a
martyr for spending 68 days in there I
know people have been trapped in there
for years who've given all hope of
escape and accepted their lot in life
they became the Elders of a lot of these
communities helping others adjust though
of course generalissimo vartagen was not
one of these people myself Vicki and
Kelvin were dragged by The Stranger
stressed as staff members into a fort
made of smashed up wood nailed together
into a huge ominous structure it was a
far more extensive structure than any of
the communities I'd visited or even
heard about before in the infinite Ikea
it was a true Fortress guarded by many
more of those knife-wielding people
dressed in the clothes and In the Flesh
of the staff it looked like some evil
cult straight out of a damn horror movie
I've never seen anything like it we were
dragged into a kind of tent in the
middle of the camp made out of stitched
together rugs that's where we met
General lisimo verdagan surrounded by
his guards I'd later learned his
namesake was a set of steak knives
stocked in the Ikea kitchenware sections
similar to the knives being wielded by
his gallery of goons the generalissimo
himself was dressed like some absurd tin
pot dictator wearing a silly hat and a
jacket covered in fake Metals his whole
presence felt like a cosmic punishment
for daring to believe things couldn't
get any more absurd than they already
were his men forced us down onto our
knees and vardagen cleared his throat to
speak quick interferes the sight of this
Ikea's ruler Great and Powerful
generalism
I have United Kingdoms from the
gardening and bathroom supplies
departments and crushed descending
tribes in the office furniture sections
to the rest if you wish to live you will
smell healthy to me join my Legion of
sevens if you do as I say you will be
given Safety and Security from this
staff come Nightfall if you do not
Benzene me I will have you destroyed by
the time his little Spiel was done the
man was red in the face and sweating
profusely it was clear that much like
your average Ikea shelving unit after a
couple weeks of use the great
generalisimo vardagen had a few screws
loose none of us like the idea of
becoming slaves to some flat-packed
Genghis Khan so we try to persuade him
to just let us go telling him that we
hope to escape the store and with our
help he could Escape too that's when we
learned a sobering lesson for some
people life inside the infinite Ikea was
better than life outside in the real
world the generalissimo had been a twice
divorced ex-s salary man with nothing to
his name but debts and regrets but here
he was a demigod a leader among the rest
of us mere mortals why would he ever
want to go back to the world that had
given him nothing and taken everything
Day 70 to day 84. we were forced into
weeks of hard labor after that toiling
under the generalissimo and his gang of
brighams the soldiers worked us like
dogs making us carry food and furniture
back to the generalissimo's Scandinavian
furniture Fortress one day bled into the
next the best I could say about any of
this was at least we were safe Behind
the Walls of the Fortress at night so we
didn't need to worry about getting
murdered by the staff in our sleep
however tragedy struck again on day 85
Kelvin couldn't take the work anymore
one day I think his mind just snapped he
refused to follow orders from the
generalissimo and his lieutenants even
when they threatened him with death
sadly that night they would prove that
this wasn't just some empty threat when
night fell they tied up kelvin's arms
and legs and left him outside the
Fortress we were just forced to watch as
the staff assembled and beat our friend
to death while he lay there unable to
defend himself even in all the time I'd
spent in the infinite Ikea that was the
most harrowing thing I'd ever seen But
in one of the few acts of righteous
Cosmic Justice that we'd seen since
being trapped in here all those months
ago just a few days after kelvin's
brutal execution day 90 the day of the
Revolution while I'd love to tell you
that I started this there are no heroes
in the story I just happened to be the
one telling you about it some internal
conflict between the generalissimo and
his men boiled over into a kind of civil
war that tore the Fortress apart from
within Vicky and I escaped but in
different directions I'd like to imagine
she got out in the end it helps me sleep
at night but one thing I will tell you
generally simul verdagan found out what
happened to tyrants big and small when
his closest confidants give him the
Julius Caesar treatment with the knives
from which he took his name I don't
think there's anything wrong in taking a
little joy in that for days afterwards I
just walked I felt so empty but I
refused to just lay down and let myself
die even though so much of the Hope had
been beaten out of me I couldn't betray
Brenda by just giving up in here it
wouldn't be right it just wouldn't be
right the days ticked on and nothing
changed I had no food no weapons I was
getting so tired then night fell and the
staff started chasing me they seemed
even more aggressive than before I
couldn't fight all I could do was run I
ran and I ran and I ran not even looking
where I was going as the crowd of Staff
started catching up with me getting
closer and closer I ran until there was
a doorway before me I didn't even think
I just was trying to get away that's
when I noticed that the store's roof was
no longer above me for the first time in
100 days I was once again tasting fresh
air that's right folks on day 100 I was
out I truly made it out this Victory
however was short-lived a group of about
six staff members burst out of the front
door behind me charging towards me with
ferocious speed I couldn't move all I
could do was grit my teeth and winds
ready to accept my death at what had
otherwise been the high point of my
recent life what a depressing irony that
would be but instead gunshots rang out
through the air a hail of bullets
cleaved through the staff members
dropping them to the ground mere feet
away from me stone dub that's when I
turned to see a group of men with
assault rifles and tactical gear walking
towards me in any other situation this
might have been terrifying right then it
was the happiest moment of my life these
men took me away from the parking lot of
what is now and abandoned Ikea they told
me they were from a group called The SCP
Foundation and that I'd been declared
missing for some time now I didn't care
about any of that I just asked them if
Brenda had gotten out if she hadn't
escaped too then this was all for
nothing you can't even imagine my relief
when they told me that Brenda was never
even trapped she was the one who
reported my disappearance after I
dropped off the face of the Earth and
what she thought was a perfectly normal
Ikea shopping session before that
building was shut down and cordoned off
under some less insane pretense but
Brenda was alive and safe and I'd get to
be with her again I've no shame in
telling you I cried but I'd like to
specify that they were absolutely tears
of joy the men from the SCP Foundation
told me that they'd give me a medicine
that had helped me forget all this after
I told them my story and there is no
part of me that has a problem with that
some things are better left forgotten
but before the SCP Foundation wipes it
all away from my mind and I get to go
live with my beloved wife once more this
was how I survived 100 Dreadful days in
the
agent kister was running for his life
every breath had burned in his throat
like inhaling chlorine gas he sped
through the dark surrounded by deafening
metallic screams that bounced off The
Eternity of pipes scaling and strangling
the walls around him as far as he was
concerned this was what hell looked like
a nightmare boiler room that would
somehow be less scary if Freddy Krueger
was there because at least there'd be
some kind of recognizably human
intelligence to reason with the pipes
scp-015 are truly unknowable as an SCP
Foundation mobile Task Force member
agent kister had seen some truly
horrific things in the line of duty he'd
been there during scp-682 containment
breaches firing an assault rifle at the
Beast as it scales hardened into a
bulletproof carapace he'd seen the femur
breaker used on some poor godforsaken
d-class to lure Uncle Larry back into
the containment chamber for some
midnight fun in the most anxiety and
reducing mission of his life he once
even bagged 096's weeping face after it
slaughtered a whole Mountain Village and
these damn pipes were going to be the
thing that killed him he turned a sharp
corner trying to block out the screams
of his teammates four of them had been
sent in the rest were already dead or
Worse stupid
they'd made a classic military mistake
underestimating the capabilities of
their enemy and an agent kister's
experience this had always been a
capital offense all to install that
machine that stupid little remote
control reconnaissance vehicle that's
what they'd given their lives for agent
kister tried to Blink away the memory of
agent Montgomery's Face Monty was the
youngest member of the team 28 years old
his first major mission Into the Heart
of a skip kister wanted to remember him
how he'd first seen him a bright-eyed
greenhorn ready to protect the human
race from the horrors that lay in the
dark but he'd been the first to go when
everything got
f-u-b-a-r it was the smaller pipes that
got Monty four of them shot out spearing
his lungs and heart pinning him in place
even if they tried to cut him out he
would have been a goner he coughed up
blood and went ghosts white faster than
you'd ever imagine tension kister would
never forget For What Little time he had
left to live the horrible sight of the
light leaving that kid's eyes and all
this because one of them had tripped on
one of the pipes on the way out and
busted it the mission was already done
what an awful pointless way to die
kisser was yanked from his aching
Thoughts by a sudden obstacle in the way
a huge towering pipe that looked like a
pillar of Flesh covered in bulbous
staring eyes the thought crossed his
mind Jesus these pipes can really be
made out of anything he looked down and
saw a series of rubber pipes slithering
towards his feet along the ground like
snakes it was time to run again but how
long could you even run for when the
very location around you wants you dead
they should have sent the mole rats for
a job like this the infinitely
reconfiguring pipes changed the layout
of the warehouse around him making
Escape seem all the more unfeasible
that's when he started thinking about
the terrible thing that happened to
agent green when 015 turned hostile they
needed to make a run for it fast it
wasn't unlike being a pathogen inside a
living body you start to make trouble
and the body's immune system is going to
come for you and one of the most common
mechanisms for a body fighting a virus
is a fever a sudden increase in
temperature that burns out the threat
the group turned and ran as the pipe
started twisting towards them agent
green panicked and began striking at the
pipes around him with his hands the
first instinct would have been to shoot
but no guns were permitted inside the
scp-015 warehouse it reacted severely to
any kind of tool being brought into its
proximity several dead agents and
researchers could tell you all about
this if they hadn't made that same
mistake but when things were already
going sideways it left them defenseless
agent green was soon boxed in caged by a
latticework of pipes in varying sizes he
tried desperately to push them out of
the way and make an Escape Route but the
hissing noise was getting louder and
louder as the pipes started to turn a
glowing red all around him after all
when a body needs to deal with a hostile
foreign object it burns out the threat
kister wish he could shake the awful
high-pitched whale that agent green made
while the heat inside his pipe cage
became unbearable it was like seeing a
human get caught inside a giant bug
zapper his skin went black and charred
and soon after the heat had risen to
such an insane degree that agent green
was reduced to little more than Ash in
his pipe furnace but kister couldn't
afford to dwell he kept running vaulting
over a long ragged pipe made from
stinking human hair this terrible Place
stank of motor oil mold and death but
maybe those perceptions had been colored
by the Terrible Things he'd seen here
there was again that awful choked
screaming coming from inside the pipes
agent Boggs it was a nightmare to hear
him shriek like the that Boggs had been
one of the toughest men that kissed her
had ever met he mentored him back when
he first became an MTF member having
bogs on the team meant experience had
been safety it meant that things would
go okay kister had seen vogg stare down
some of the most horrifying skips
imaginable and not even Flinch and yet
here he was screaming and bawling like a
hurt child in the pipes Boggs was the
next one to get taken as he and kissed
her ran through the dark trying to find
a way out they'd passed a huge pipe made
of a soft foam-like substance a seam in
the side of the pipe had yawned open and
a tangle of writhing tentacles each one
Barbed with thorns like the stem of a
rose bush they enveloped agent Boggs
cutting into his weathered skin he
gasped in pain unable to scream it
happened so fast before Kester even had
a chance to grab him he was pulled into
the pipe and the crevice sealed behind
him and that was when the screaming
really started for poor agent Bob
kister hoped for his sake that he would
die sometime soon shrouded in the fog of
his dark thoughts agent kister turned a
corner and felt cold hard metal suddenly
collided with his face breaking his nose
with an unpleasant crunch he'd been
clotheslined by a low pipe that hadn't
been there before and now he was laid
out on his back face humming with pain
thoughts and feelings swam he looked up
into these seemingly infinite web of
pipes weaving through the air above him
he was right earlier he just knew it the
place was held it'd be his eternal
resting place suddenly a new huge shape
moved into the space above him a pipe of
ancient rusty iron that looked older
than even the warehouse holding this
whole mess right above him there was a
huge valve fixed into the pipe's belly
he watched helpless as the valve opened
itself with a squeal and a huge Dark
Mask came pouring out of it onto his
body a sudden weight a sudden War
sound and movement and Tiny scratching
claws rats thousands of big hungry black
rats with gnarled yellow teeth clumps of
fur Purge from their skin by mange big
ropey worm-like Tails swaying and
whipping at the air who knows how long
they've been in that pipe who knows when
these rats had eaten anything that
wasn't their brothers and sisters and
here was agent kister given unto them by
the Glorious pipes the last thing he
ever saw were those nasty yellow teeth
because they ate his eyes first where do
the four disappeared and presumed dead
operatives soon reached Dr Charles Ogden
gears the legendarily tack turned senior
researcher that managed the scp-015
project among a myriad of others his
face didn't betray a flicker of emotion
when he was informed about the men lost
to
scp-015 it wasn't that he didn't feel
for them nor that he deemed it both
unproductive and unprof professional to
dwell on the deaths of personnel when
carrying out their duties after all
being killed by an anomaly was simply an
occupational hazard and a generous
stipend would be sent to their families
to compensate for their tragic loss Dr
gears simply asked was the mission
successful in spite of the casualties
did the team manage to install the
modular robotic vehicle at the epicenter
he was told that the mrv had been
successfully installed at least Dr gears
nodded and began scheduling a second
exploratory mission for a few months in
the future to check the status of the
machine still in the meantime the mrv
would chug along doing what humans
couldn't or perhaps shouldn't do within
the nightmarish mess of ever-growing
pipes it would roll through collecting
information on everything around it
hopefully giving the SCP Foundation an
in-road to mapping the whole thing
without needing to send a convocative
staff Into the Danger Zone just to
discover more about these peculiar
earlier pipes sure some lives were lost
getting in there but this measure would
likely save even more lives in the long
run that was until something went wrong
the exact nature of what happened to the
mrv inside the domain of pipes was a
mystery but it wasn't doing its intended
job and the SCP Foundation needed to
find out why the second exploratory
mission was required much sooner than
they'd initially anticipated with a dual
purpose collecting the readings and
finding out what exactly had happened to
the mrv in the first place he included a
more specific set of instructions for
the next mission only three members of
personnel to enter
scp-015 this time to minimize potential
loss one trained technician to collect
and read the Diagnostics and two guards
to maintain discipline and safety under
pressure with a setup like that what
could possibly go wrong Dr gears's
various assist began headhunting the
perfect team for the job Junior
researcher Lon wanting to prove herself
and climb up the ranks put her name
forward she was young intelligent and
had the initiative to get the job done
though there was one thing that she
hadn't disclosed when she was applying
for this important new position Junior
researcher lawn suffered from
claustrophobia the fear of enclosed
spaces then the hunt was on for the two
members of foundation military personnel
who'd escort lawn to the mrv to take the
readings like the two priests in The
Exorcist they decided to recruit one
grizzled experienced operative and one
extremely cautious Young Buck straight
out of the foundation MTF Training
Academy the younger of the two
operatives codenamed agent 2 was careful
and conscientious to a fault he did
things by the book or not at all the
older operative codenamed agent 6 was
quite the opposite he done this job long
enough to operate solely on Instinct and
resented his employers for expecting him
to approach his missions any other way
long agent 2 and agent 6. the team was
assembled and when the time came they
were taken to scp-015 to execute their
mission it should have been simple
enough get in collect the readings and
get that count though a few weeks
earlier the same thing would have been
said for the mission to install the mrv
which left for mobile task force
operatives dead or Worse nothing was
ever as simple as it seemed when it came
to
scp-015 they were only allowed
flashlights inside anything else carried
a substantial risk of activating
scp-015's defensive State putting all of
their lives in Jeopardy Bond had tried
to keep things light masking her own
terrible fear at this strange news
situation she joked that perhaps the
three of them should get Mario hats
seeing as they were plumbers now agent 2
had happily laughed along suggesting
that perhaps he should be Luigi agent 6
was utterly unamused by this whole
situation and wanted no part of it which
is honestly just so Wario of him they
followed along a carefully mapped route
through the pipes being careful not to
touch any of them after all you never
know what could set
scp-015 off agent 6 didn't share in
their merriment or their concern in fact
he had contempt for them and this whole
situation he thought lawn and agent 2
were a pair of frightened skittish
children willing to buy whatever
foundation-assigned bull honky they were
given he didn't believe that scp-015 was
anywhere near as dangerous as they'd
been told in all likelihood knowing the
Eggheads up top they just didn't want
men of action like him breaking any of
their precious little toys while
conducting missions on their behalf this
whole thing was a big stupid joke as
they ducked and weaved through the
confines of scp-015 the tensions be
between them all just silently grew
their flashlights played among the pipes
revealing the insane variety of shapes
sizes compositions and materials in here
wood steel flesh bone glass pressed Ash
granite and so much more and yet there
were no pipes comprised of any standard
pipe making material like lead PVC
plastic or copper it was undeniably
freaky but when you work with scps for
long enough you learn to stop asking
questions about the more minor forms of
strangeness inherent to anomalies the
composition only got narrower as they
delved deeper into the warehouse lawn
felt the anxiety like a hand gripping
her throat and squeezing but trying
still to keep it hidden agent 6 the
largest among them almost got stuck a
few times trying to crawl into spaces
too tight for him to fit he felt like
murdering lawn when she threw out a
casual comparison to Winnie the Pooh and
the cross success when they reached the
mrv it gave them an ounce of momentary
relief the journey was halfway done but
the Comfort was quickly squashed by
seeing what had actually happened to the
mrv it had been speared by a pipe and
new pipes had grown through and out of
it effectively rooting it in place this
caused immediate debate among the group
around one key issue did this mean that
the mrv was now technically part of the
pipes and by extension would the pipes
feel the need to defend themselves if
the data banks were removed from the mrv
in order to deliver the readings back to
the researchers at site 17 while lawn
and agent 2 carefully discussed the
issue agent 6 lost his temper and
decided to show these two foolish kids
how it was done he claimed the two of
them were worrying about a bunch of
foundation Hui that they were an
experienced and gullible enough to
believe as if this bunch of weird pipes
was actually dangerous it was like how
every six anomalies there's Apparently
one capable of ending the world it's all
a bunch of overblown fear-mongering
nonsense and to prove that he wasn't
just all talk on this front agent 6
pried open the top of the mrv and slid
out the data cards which seemed to be
covered in some kind of viscous
unpleasant liquid from the pipes that
had penetrated the device still he'd
gotten what they came for he could have
done this whole thing alone without this
pair of bedwetters he scoffed and said
kids I don't know how you two survive
but he shouldn't have spoken so soon the
large pipe that he didn't even realize
he was standing on opened up beneath his
feet and seconds later he was immersed
up to his shoulders in it six began to
let out the most horrifying shrieks
you've ever heard and when agent 2 and
Lawn ran over to try and help him out
they realized why the pipe below agent 6
was filled with flowing molten Iron by
the time they pulled agent 6 out well
agent 6 from the shoulders up
considering that that was all that was
left he was on already dead and despite
the actual aggressor being destroyed
scp-015 wasn't done it was ready to
clean house as agent 2 and Lon attempted
to flee some eye level pipes around them
burst firing crystallized glass into
their faces cutting into their skin and
eyes but they needed to push on despite
the pain if they wanted to survive and
get out the two of them ran horrifying
noises of twisting and bursting pipes
roaring behind them pipes made of thorns
and Bones started to grow blocking off
their exits until they were trapped Bond
utilizing her small frame was able to
crawl through a gap in the pipes into an
adjoining chamber two was given a
horrifying surprise when a pipe burst
near his hand showering his flesh in
thick corrosive Gunk his hand melted
away at the wrist as long called for
help in the tiny cram chamber she was
locked in two ran off to try and find an
exit where he could bring more people in
to help them but it would already be 2
too late for poor lawn a thick
honey-like substance began bleeding into
the chamber disgusting and its
overpowering saccharine flavor and goopy
viscous thickness the chamber seemed to
get smaller and smaller as Lon screamed
as the honey level Rose eventually it
got higher than her mouth and nose could
reach she gave a horrifying final gurgle
and then she was gone entombed forever
between the pipes agent 2 kept running
his flashlight was beginning to die but
he didn't care as his eyes bled from the
splinters of glass and what was left of
his hand dripped from the jagged nub of
his wrist all he could do was keep
moving forwards he panted and screamed
and stumbled in the dark until he
tripped on something he didn't notice
and pitched forwards he tumbled into the
gaping maw of a nearby pipe surrounded
by unseeable unknowable ooze as he
tumbled further down into the seemingly
infinite Darkness it was too dark to see
and too cramped to move anywhere but
straight down all he could do was scream
and scream and scream until his voice
was hoarse and his throat bled though
nobody was there to even hear his cries
days later when his skin started to
shred off it was almost welcome Dr gears
would later receive the news of this
tragically failed Mission and the three
operatives now declared M.I.A because of
it he sighed and wrote up his report on
the matter closing with the sentence
data deemed non-vital in light of lost
staff
scp-015 classification level review
suggested the foundation was in chaos
one minute Dr bright was looking into
some harmless products on Amazon to help
the foundation's anomalies have a nicer
experience in their cells the next he
was physically fighting for his life
against the company's CEO of course Dr
Bright's wacky Antics have revealed the
location of the SCP foundation's most
valuable containment site to Jeff Bezos
and his Legions of min onions does Dr
Jack Bright have it in him to fix his
mistake defeat the mighty Jeff Bezos and
save the SCP Foundation from corporate
servitude of the forces of the SCP
Foundation equal in strength to the
Amazon horde and how at the 11th Hour
will anomalies like
scp-096
scp-682
SCP-173 and scp-049 helped save the day
buckle up the only way to find out is to
keep watching the two Titans Dr bright
and the freakishly buffed Jeff Bezos
were locked into an intense struggle the
hapless Immortal tried his best to punch
and kick the augmented CEO but all it
did was make Bezos laugh pathetic Jack
Bezos roared let me show you how a real
man does it with one punch Bezos sent Dr
bright skidding across the dirt seeing
Stars Bezos punched him so hard Dr
bright felt like he'd been hit by a
runaway truck where had he even gotten
all this anomalous technology something
more was going on here but before Dr
Bryant could collect his thoughts Bezos
was already upon him the ruthless
business Mogul clasped his hands
together and brought them down onto the
back of Jack's head in a brutal pile
Drive burying his head in the dirt the
guards of sight 19 looked on in Terror
at the thousands of Amazon troops
surrounding them and they were betting
all this on a fistfight and what's more
it didn't even look like Dr bright was
winning that fight unless the good
doctor used his special move Bezos still
cackling like a Saturday morning cartoon
villain grabbed Dr bright by his hair
and dragged him out of the dirt he
lifted the doctor bloody and bashed with
one hand at that moment Dr bright knew
that he had to go with the nuclear
option here he needed to use
scp-963 to take over the body of Jeff
Bezos and end this demented War had
enough Jack Bezos said or do you want me
to humiliate you even more in front of
your sad little employees or should I
say my sad little employees
without another word Dr Wright grabbed
the amulet hanging around his neck and
bawled it into his fist moving as
quickly as he could he lunged at Bezos
with The Medallion knowing that one
touch should be enough to finish this
whole thing but then the unexpected
happened Bezos caught Dr Bright's hand
the Flesh of the CEO's fist turned
obsidian black he gave a cruel smirk he
was still himself impossible all the SCP
Foundation staff in attendance were
shocked and horrified but none more than
Dr bright himself this was the first
time that scp-963 simply hadn't worked I
I don't understand Jack said voice
trembling as Bezos squeezed his hand
with an iron grip I should have taken
you over how is this possible Bezos
chuckled before unleashing a brutal
headbutt on Dr bright throwing him back
through the air bright was lucky he
managed to keep a grip on The Medallion
this body hadn't worn it for 30 days if
he dropped it it would have just been
another useless necklace Nano machine
son meso sparked cracking his neck back
into place I
am in anywhere your necklace
necklace my genetics to turn that flesh
into inanimate pseudomound do you think
I'd lead an assault on the SCP
Foundation without planning for every
possible eventuality I've been playing
the long game it was at this point the
foundation guards assembled outside the
building opened fire on Bezos but it was
no use the bullets just ricocheted off
of his anomalously enhanced physique he
just gave a bellowing laugh and ordered
the full strength of his forces to move
in as far as he was concerned the fight
was already won if their forces could
plant the grinning Amazon flag in the
heart of sight 19 the SCP Foundation
would be his it was time for the true
final battle to begin Amazon's troops
loaded their weapons and charged firing
volley after volley of bullets onto the
foundation's guards entrenched in their
positions of course the foundation
Personnel was better trained but the
Amazon Army outnumbered them ten to one
it was only a matter of time until the
barricades gave way and the forces
spilled into the contain facility and
then they did inside the building Dr
clef was reading his new copy of
shotguns a comprehensive guide when the
Army breached the perimeter it was at
this point that he put down the book and
picked up his favorite shotgun a
Remington Model 1187 fun fact also the
preferred weapon of Anton sugar from No
Country for Old Men and entered The Fray
they'd need every SCP Foundation hand on
Deck to repel the incoming attack the
one thing that not even Dr cleff
predicted was for the anomalies to get
involved too you see in ordering his
troops to attack site 19 the fleet of
Amazon Attack Helicopters above began
launching agm-114 Hellfire missiles at
the building to knock out guard towers
and strategic Communications arrays this
however had the unintended effect of
causing power fluctuations within the
building and with so many of the reserve
generators devoted to maintaining
external security against the Amazon
Army internal security failed entirely
in other words a whole lot of cell doors
were popping open a group of Amazon foot
soldiers were making their way down
hallway 6C when they saw something
strange on the ground a tide of green
bubbling chemicals that produced a
horrific smell little did they know this
was powerful hydrochloric acid but in
this instance it wasn't the acid they
should be worried about they heard a
raspy voice behind them say disgusting
that's when they turned to see scp-682
the giant rage-fueled Immortal reptile
standing right behind them it had just
finished its exotic beef jerky
collection and now it was eager for
seconds the Amazon soldiers panicked and
began to open fire on the beast but all
that succeeded in doing was annoying it
scp-682 leaped onto them and began
devouring the group of hapless
mercenaries alive elsewhere in the
facility another group of Amazon
mercenaries were chasing some
defenseless SCP Foundation researchers
through the secure humanoid containment
Wing the researchers tried to run but
soon they were backed into a corner The
Mercenaries laughed and leveled their
assault rifles this would be an easy
kill however the second they tried to
fire they realized something extremely
strange had occurred all of their guns
had turned into delightful bouquets
standing between them and the
researchers they intended to kill was
scp-343 also known to some as God now
now boys
scp-343 said with a slight smile can't
we all just get along Make Love Not War
frightened by these seemingly impossible
act they just witnessed the now unarmed
mercenaries ran into a nearby room with
a sturdy looking door and locked
themselves in hopefully nobody would get
them here that thought was interrupted
by a grandiose voice with an archaic
French accent speaking out behind them
why hello there good sirs so kind of you
to step into my practice today they
turned and saw a strange robed man
wearing a runner pigeon mask the figure
removed the mask only to reveal what
seemed like another strange beaked mask
underneath it was scp-049 his desk
covered in pleasingly polished Amazon
medical tools my my Eugen seem a little
under the weather this is cause for
concern the plague doctor said as he
began to walk towards the frightened
mercenaries the pestilence runs right
days not to worry though I am an expert
and I've been itching to try out my
lovely new tools horrified screaming was
heard from the room shortly after then
silence but Amazon troops kept pouring
in it was an all-out assault Beyond any
that site 19 had ever experienced some
Amazon strike teams were making their
way through the break rooms hunting for
more Foundation employees to capture or
execute one of them remarked that these
SCP Foundation employees must be real
head cases why else would they keep such
hideous concrete sculptures in their
break room utterly bizarre the second
they found there was no one inside and
turned to leave the room they all laid
dead on the ground with snapped necks
that would make it 17 Amazon mercenaries
they'd killed today the sculpture was
having a truly wonderful time meanwhile
over in his office Dr cleff was fighting
for his life a group of Junior
researchers were taking refuge and
they're with him and handing him shotgun
shells from his many many boxes of them
when he needed to reload Soldier after
Soldier was running into the room and
clef was using his trusty Remington pump
action to blow them away with Incredible
Precision every time one of them ran in
an austruck researcher asked how are you
this good with that thing clef laughed
and said kid I could unbutton your lab
coat with it but then tragedy struck Dr
clef ran out of shells he signed and
told the assembled researchers to run
out of the back exit and save themselves
he'd hold back the tide of Amazon
mercenaries alone he kissed his shotgun
and said forgive me for this Remy then
grabbed it by the barrel if he couldn't
shoot with it he'd at least use it as a
club he ran out into The Fray bashing
down mercenaries left and right with his
shotgun Club until he was finally
outnumbered a group of heavily armed
soldiers surrounded him holding him at
gunpoint one of them gave the order to
fire wait Dr clef said I can be valuable
to you you don't know who I am do you
give me a second let me show you my ID
Dr clef pulled an id1 from his lab coat
and then showed it to the soldiers they
looked at it confused and a little
Disturbed the leader of the group said
that's not an ID card you schmuck what
the hell is that ugly thing anyway by
this point Dr Cliff had already closed
his eyes a distant screaming got closer
and closer until the wall of his office
exploded
scp-096 entered the room shrieking with
rage and began tearing the hapless
soldiers to shreds Cliff rolled away
keeping his eyes closed and waiting for
the Carnage to be over but in a grander
sense the Carnage had only just begun oh
and for those who were curious yes
scp-811 did get her blobfish plushie she
loved it outside the facility Jeff Bezos
looked upon the destruction he rocked
and laughed it was just as wonderful as
he did mentioned it in all his years of
intense planning for this very moment it
all unfolded exactly to his design the
SCP Foundation would fall and his master
plan would finally be complete Dr Jack
Bright demoralized but not defeated Roe
shakely to his feet this whole disaster
had been his fault he had to redeem this
he had to defeat Jeff Bezos or the
foundation would fall into his iron
clutches even if it finally truly killed
him Dr bright would not give up
impressive tack Dr bright said cracking
his knuckles and getting Jeff's
attention again which Sweatshop built it
for you Jeff just laughed and turned to
Bright again more than ready for round
two a little place called Prometheus
Labs Jack Jeff said remember them I was
on the board of directors before the
incident just like you and your
foundation dogs they left behind plenty
of goodies for me Dr bright charged at
Bezos screaming in animal Fury he
punched the smug anomalous businessman
Square in the jaw Bezos barely even
flinched he gave Jack an utterly brutal
open-handed slap knocking him towards
the entrance to site 19 where more
Amazon soldiers were still pouring in
still Jack began to stand again what
the hell does a corporate stiff like you
want with the SCP Foundation he said we
want to help the world not rule it Bezos
sneered and began stomping towards the
immortal doctor I don't just want to
rule the world Jack I want to hold it in
my hand like an apple and take a big
juicy bite all that exists will belong
to me he said throwing a punch that Dr
bright was thankfully able to dodge
that's always been the plan and the SCP
Foundation is the final piece I need Dr
bright summoning all the adrenaline in
his body Unleashed a flurry of sharp
punches to Jeff's abdomen he simply
tanked every strike and laughed I've
been funding the chaos Insurgency for
years Jack I'm one of Marshall Carter
and dark's largest shareholders Amazon
is Dr wondertainment's primary Global
distributor the sarkists the fifthis the
mechanites those pretentious art snots
are we cool yet they're all in my Deep
Pockets Jeff roard he wrapped one of his
massive hands around Dr Bright's throats
and lifted him clear off the ground Jack
struggled against his grip you've spent
decades worrying about all the wrong
things Jack Jeff said slowly tightening
his grip around Dr Bright's throat the
Devourer of world the black moon the
Scarlet King my new world won't have a
king it'll have a CEO and with The Power
Within These Walls I'll be the chairman
of the cosmic war and it all starts with
me killing you and turning your silly
little necklace into a paperweight but
Jack had an ace up his sleeve something
he had the good sense to pocket before
facing Bezos on the battlefield he
reached into his lab coat and pulled out
scp-662 the butler's handbell one little
ring in Mr Deeds suddenly appeared right
next to them Jack barely managed to
wheeze out
kick Jeff in the groin of course sir Mr
Deeds said before doing exactly that
Jeff Winston Payne and loosened his grip
on Dr Bright's neck the Plucky Immortal
took his chance to wriggle free from
Jeff's grip and run into the facility
yelling back dude stall him but before
Deeds could execute this order Jeff
Bezos fractured the anomalous Butler's
skull with a single punch and chased Dr
bright into the facility he would have
his revenge as Dr bright fled he'd
grabbed his foundation walkie-talkie and
frantically spoke into it Cliff I'm in
big trouble I think I have a way to stop
this but there's just something you need
to do for me first battles were raging
throughout the site some Amazon soldiers
had unloaded their rifles into Kane only
to find themselves on the floor dying of
massive blood loss other squadrons of
mercenaries were being tortured by the
nightmarish scp-106 in his terrifying
pocket Dimension he was having a
wonderful time
scp-999 was even tickling a gaggle of
Amazon's hired veteran war criminals
into absolute submission much to Jeff's
rage and horror it looked like with the
help of the anomalies the foundation
might actually be able to turn the tide
this would not do he'd destroy bright
and take care of the rest personally it
has to be this way Jack Bezos yelled
after the fleeing doctor I'm making the
mother of all corporate omelets here
can't fret over a few ransacked
containment sites bezos's
self-aggrandizing rants were interrupted
by a cp682 leaping onto him out of an
adjoining hallway giving Dr bright even
more time to create distance between
them 682 fought valiantly and viciously
but Jeff's Prometheus Labs Nano machine
augmentations gave him the edge he was
able to get to scp-682 into a headlock
Steve Irwin style then punch it in the
head until it was knocked out Jeff's
side relieved and continued to chase
after Jack as Jeff turned a corner to
chase Dr bright he ran right into one of
Jack's traps there was Dr bright
standing about 15 feet away from
holding his favorite item that he
normally wasn't allowed to use the
chainsaw Cannon Jack smirkton said smile
you son of a boom a chainsaw projectile
blasted towards Jeff at incredible
speeds it was through pure luck and
superhuman reflexes that Jeff was able
to catch it between his palms by the
blade and hold it in place even as it
cut into his nanite hardened skin with
the grunt of Rage he threw the saw into
the ground is that all you got Jack he
growled not quite Dr bright replied I've
got a few friends who owe me some favors
suddenly Bezos heard footsteps behind
him he turned to see three figures
standing there primed and ready for
battle
scp-4494 the Specter
scp-5151 the Black Knight and scp-2800
Cactus man you'll fight without honor
Sir Jeffrey the Black Knight proclaimed
as he drew his long sword I and I can't
stand bullies said cactus man as the
spikes began to grow wage theft and tax
evasion is a crime evil doer the Specter
added well then Jeff said I suppose I'll
just have to kill you all the fight
began a group of four Heroes held their
own impressively to begin with they
consistently helped each other block or
avoid the deadly strikes that Bezos was
unleashing and returning their own four
anomalies against one the Black Knight
even gave Dr bright one of his spare
swords to give him a better chance of
Landing a meaningful blow against Bezos
but in the end it was all for nothing
Bezos powered up his Nano machines
drawing energy from the building around
him until he was even larger and
stronger in his State he easily beat
down his four attackers incapacitating
them and standing over bright it's
useless Jack he said with another evil
laugh you can't beat me I Know Jack
groaned in pain but I did a pretty good
job of stalling you at that moment clef
came running down the hall wielding
another firearm but it wasn't a shotgun
this time in fact it didn't even look
like a real gun it looked like a
spray-painted Nerf gun that got another
laugh out of Jeff what an utterly feeble
attempt that's when Dr clef leveled the
Nerf gun and fired one of its starts
against Jeff's chest where it seemed to
bounce off uselessly really he asked
incredulous come on this is just getting
his words were cut off by an uppercut
from Dr bright inexplicably he actually
felt that one Jeff staggered back
rubbing his jaw as bright Rose to his
feet how the hell did you hurt me Jeff
muttered genuinely shocked Dr bright
smirked that was the nerfing gun
chromedome we just made your precious
Nano machines useless with another
incredibly well-earned punch in the face
from Dr bright Jeff was down on the
ground with a bleeding nose elsewhere in
the facility the researchers guards and
anomalies working together had defeated
the dark Forces of Amazon outside hammer
town the largest and most militarily
powerful mobile task force had arrived
and wiped out what remained of Jeff's
Invasion Force outside it wasn't easy
but the SCP Foundation had won as Jeff
lay on the ground holding his broken
nose Dr bright held him at sword Point
wait wait Jeff said that's not let hard
feelings linger we're both adults right
and I'm a businessman I make deals
compromises I can give you anything from
the Amazon stock free of charge as long
as we agree that I can go and we forget
all about this Dr bright smiled and
thought it over well he said there are
few things I'd like for myself and there
are still plenty more anomalies that
need enriching Victory secured want
another video about the deranged things
Dr bright bought for even more anomalies
and Foundation staff let us know down in
the comments and we'll continue the
strangest story that the SCP
foundation's most eccentric researcher
ever told 2AM a few miles outside the
city the car tore down the asphalt at 60
miles an hour we kept the beams low the
dark Road around us only illuminated by
the occasional Street Lamp overhead
things moved unseen in the trees an old
song rattled off the radio the
connection was patchy so it was
interrupted by intermittent spikes of
static it was the kind of night when you
knew deep down that anything could
happen you just hoped that anything
would be in your favor I rolled the
window down a few minutes ago breathing
in all that cold fresh air to Stave off
the looming Specter of sleep thank God I
wasn't the one driving but things would
have gotten deadly way sooner cops would
have found us with our bumper wrapped
around a tree our heads won with the
steering wheel or the windshield dead on
impact or from the unforgiving cold
overnight it might have even felt sorry
for us until they found the case perhaps
it would have been better that way at
least it would have been quick a lot of
bad things can happen on lonely State
highways in the dead of night and we
were about to find out the just crashing
your car was one of the more mild ones
Scott was driving he was was also the
one who brokered this whole deal I was
just coming along to provide backup
there was a fully loaded Saturday Night
Special sitting in my inner coat pocket
hoping that I wouldn't see any action
tonight and a pump action shotgun
sitting in the back in case things got
really hairy deals like this you either
come well prepared or reckon with a
heavy chance you sure as hell won't be
leaving I never asked Scott how he came
into the goods currently sitting in the
briefcase and he never offered an
explanation either he only told me that
he'd already secured a very interested
potential buyer from a Syndicate out of
town serious people dangerous people
they'd pay top dollar or leave us tied
up in trash bags in a ditch off the side
of the highway but we both needed money
and we are willing to take that risk if
it meant we could return from the steel
as a pair of rich men the terms of the
deal were simple we drive out onto a
certain State Highway at a little after
2 A.M with the goods meet the buyers at
a certain rest stop along the way and
make the exchange we then all go our
separate ways and if we were lucky none
of us would ever see each other ever
again seemed simple enough sure Scott
seemed downright chipper about the whole
thing and for a little while I was
excited too until he told me about the
road that the buyers wanted to meet us
on we'd all heard legends about the
place superstitions really people think
criminals are scary but believe me we're
a surprisingly superstitious Bunch our
profession is one largely based on luck
being in the right place at the right
time and being lucky enough to avoid the
cops along the way but something you
need to know whether you're a criminal
or Arrow straight is that some places
are always going to be the wrong place
I'm not going to tell you which road it
is I know what you Knuckleheads are like
you're curious you're Thrill Seekers hey
we're all young once but if I tell you
what this road is I know you're gonna
try to find it maybe you'll even decide
it's worth a trip down for a pleasant
Sunday Drive
after what I went through on that road I
wouldn't wish it tripped down it on my
worst enemy there's no other word for
what we encountered there other than
evil when we were kids we used to call
it the devil's passage every spooky
rumor and scary story in the book
circulated about that place
[Music]
let me see what I can remember well
there was The Watcher in the woods
people used to say that there was a Long
Tall figure with the biggest eyes you'd
ever seen eyes like headlights standing
amongst the trees if the Moonlight Shone
in the right angle as you were driving
past you'd see it standing there just
staring at you thinking about doing who
knows what then there was old Beth the
ghostly hitchhiker people used to say
they saw a strange old woman hobbling
down the side of the road in the middle
of the night sometimes people said that
they could hear her crying even if they
were far enough away to make such a
thing seem impossible if you took pity
on her and pulled over asking her if she
needed a ride she'd tell you that you
were a very kind person but that she was
fine and dandy walking along by herself
but if you didn't stop and offer her a
lift if you just drove away well local
Legend had it that the next time you'd
see her face would be in your rear view
mirror as she sat in your back seat
reaching for you with her ancient bony
claws it'd make you think advice about
leaving an old woman to walk home alone
in the dark and of course there was the
Lone jogger the stories my dad told me
about him always used to scare the hell
out of me he was a Pale Man dressed
unnaturally light for the cold winter
months jogging along the side of the
road if you looked at him he'd look back
if your eyes ever met the stories went
that he'd start running after you it
wouldn't matter how fast you drove he
had somehow always catch up and stare at
you through the glass of your car's
Windows he never hurt anyone directly
but I imagine he probably caused a heart
attack or two in his time if he ever
really existed but all these things were
nothing I repeat nothing compared to the
Phantom Cruiser you have to drive
cautiously at night cause if you didn't
you might find a ghostly 1970s police
cruiser tailgating you and that'd be the
worst thing you ever saw there were
fewer stories about this one than all
the others because if you ever ran a
foul at the Phantom Cruiser chances are
that you wouldn't survive to tell people
about what happened to you though people
could still make an educated guess about
what happened to you based on whatever
was left behind here's a not so fun fact
the devil's passage is technically
qualified for one of the most dangerous
highways in the country from crashes to
hitchhiker murders to unexplained deaths
on the side of the road since 1974 this
road has been an incredibly unpleasant
place to drive every time I saw another
horror story about a strange death on
the road I'd think of the Phantom
Cruiser and it was those same thoughts
polluting my brain that night as Scott
drove the two of us to the rest stop
halfway down the devil's passage I only
realized I dozed off when he nudged me
awake and the blurry lights of distant
Street lamps flashed into my field of
vision look alive he said we're here the
rest stop wasn't much to look at all
that there was was an abandoned gas
station really the perfect place for
this kind of illicit deal my hand moved
instinctively to the special in my code
and clicked back the hammer something
about this whole setup wasn't right
staying operation police Ambush this
whole thing of a deal too good to be
true my instincts turned out to be right
in the sense just not the way I was
expecting as we turned into the rest
stop Scott turned up his beams all we
saw was Carnage waiting for us a car
presumably one that once belonged to our
prospective buyers and a state of
horrific disarray it looked as though a
train had impacted the side of the
vehicle completely caving it in the
metal was covered in deep scratches and
ruts that almost looked like claw marks
it had been eviscerated Scott broke hard
we both got out of the car I drew the
special out of my jacket and he grabbed
the shotgun out of the back seat we
approached with caution worrying this
might just be another part of the setup
until we saw the thick puddle of blood
congealing under the driver's side door
we drew closer propelled by morbid
curiosity was it a hit from a rival gang
looking to intercept the deal seemed
logical but there were no bullet holes
in the car just ripping tearing and
massive impact damage Scott shined the
light of his phone into this Droid car
and I vomited when I saw what was inside
the buyers looked less like people and
more like two sacks of pulled pork and
tattered clothes if I hadn't seen them
inside the car I wouldn't have even
guessed they were human and the Damage
wasn't just to them the upholstery was
torn up and burned with violent symbols
carved into the walls and scrawled onto
the cracked windows and blood when I
turned to Scott he was Ghost white
clutching his phone and shotgun with
Trembling Hands we didn't exchange a
word but we both knew it was time to
leave we could find another buyer or be
other opportunities other deals but
lives you only get one and we both
silently acknowledge that if we stuck
around here much longer we wouldn't even
have that we sped back into the car and
locked the doors behind us for whatever
good that would do considering the
damage that had been done to the buyers
in their car perhaps we just needed the
illusion of security to get us the hell
out of there the car pulled out of the
rest stop at Breakneck speed Scott
floored it trying to put some good
distance between us and the horror at
that rest stop whatever had happened to
the buyers we didn't fancy sharing that
same awful fate my heart dropped down to
my guts when I heard the sirens and
flashing lights behind us after all this
we'd been busted for speeding they'd
pull us over and find the guns in the
briefcase in the car and they'd have a
lot of questions that neither of us
would have good answers to we didn't
know whether to slow down and hope for
the best or speed up and take this boy
in Blue on a genuine car chase this
whole thing couldn't have gone wrong but
my thoughts soon drifted from getting
used to the taste of prison food to
something altogether more Sinister when
I saw the car getting closer in the
rearview mirror I realized that this
wasn't a modern cop car tailing us it
was a beat up old 70s Cruiser traveling
at insane speeds gaining on us the high
beams cut through me like razor blades I
heard the radio crackle into life even
though neither I nor Scott touched it it
wasn't music just a hoarse scratchy
voice repeating the word run again and
again and seeing as whatever was behind
us clearly wasn't a real cop we were
more than happy to oblige that request
Scott hit the gas like our lives
depended on it which to be fair they did
but no matter how fast we sped up the
cruiser kept getting closer like a demon
on our tail I screamed at Scott to go
faster but we were going as fast as we
could next thing I knew the Phantom
Cruiser collided with the backside of
our car and sent us into a spin
showering the two of us with broken
glass crystals as the tires screeched
across the asphalt felt like an eternity
before the car came to arrest and at
that moment the Phantom Cruiser stopped
too someone got out he was dressed like
a cop he even looked like a cop a dude
in his 40s balding overweight with a
handlebar mustache but something was
wrong about him he didn't say a word as
he approached the car and he didn't seem
to register me sliding the special out
of my jacket either he was inches away
from Scott's Window when I panicked and
opened fire sending a hail of small
caliber rounds into a sky he stumbled
back slightly as though shocked and then
everything got a whole lot worse the cop
let out the most awful Bellow not of
pain but of pure rage something happened
to his face his eyes started to Glow a
bright hellish red and his jaw began to
extend until he looked like a Munch
painting with no teeth in there just an
infinite black void he grabbed a day
Scott through the window pulling him
into a brutal headlock and dragging him
out of the car releasing those deranged
Bellows the entire time Scott screamed
and pleaded for help and grabbed his
body and tried to pull him back but the
cop was inhumanly strong he just kept
pulling until he was all the way out
thrashing on the asphalt I I don't want
to tell
you right but suffice to say I couldn't
save Scott and I definitely didn't want
it happening to me while he was working
on Scott I scrambled into the driver's
seat and floored it hoping that Scott
would at least buy me some time I was
weeping in Terror as I drove away into
the dark leaving my friend to a horrible
fate with the driver of the Phantom
Cruiser so you can only imagine how I
felt when a few minutes later I heard
the sirens again and saw the bright
lights getting closer behind me run run
run
the year was 1991. it was a quiet night
in lethargy Valley Arizona the quietest
town in all of Maricopa County seriously
despite the hardcore Arizona dry heat
this is one of the most idyllic little
towns you could imagine everyone who
lived there knew each other by name and
regularly invited their neighbors to
Wholesome neighborhood cookouts the
town's historic Main Street had an
old-fashioned ice cream parlor a
knitting supply store and even a
Build-A-Bear Workshop and of course a
few local car dealerships and auto body
shops lethargy Valley really is just the
sweetest calmest place you could
possibly imagine and tonight my friends
it's going to rock while the citizens of
lethargy Valley went about their evening
duties something hardcore was heading
their way rumbling across the scorching
Arizona deserts burning fuel and
belching smog the hottest hot rods this
side of the sun will so fly they're
ready to take off with riders so badass
their own Reflections are scared of them
that's right these are the high octane
Full Throttle Adventures of the
exploding zombie Gearheads and they're
about to give this sleepy Arizona town
of Four Loco enema the sun was setting
on lethargy Valley when the lights of
distant fire cut through the night
citizens and shopkeepers and enjoying an
evening Summer Breeze halted in town as
the redness in the East got closer and
brighter they could feel the rumble of
torqued up subwoofers rattling the
ground the Roar of the engines felt more
fitting on 747s than road legal cars and
when the distance was close enough that
they could taste the vapors of burning
gasoline in the air they could finally
hear the laughter too meet
scp-3885-01 also known as the exploding
zombie Gearheads probably the most metal
of all anomalies on the SCP Foundation
catalog but let's talk about them before
these gas chugging dust devils were just
another number in the man's filing
cabinet because these bad boys don't
care about filing they only care about
defiling they rolled into lethargy
Valley like a pack of easy riding
coyotes on Gearhead steroids their skin
is Green from rot and covered in Cuts
lesions and gnarly Burns scars some have
their heads completely cracked open
exposing what little brains they have
underneath others have fully opened rib
cages and disemboweled bellies but they
don't care these ain't your grandpa's
zombies forget the Walking Dead these
dudes are the riding dead Romero meets
ratfink after 10 lines of Colombian Bam
Bam and a gallon of Monster Energy Drink
decked out in a patchwork of Motorhead
style leather and stolen clothes and you
best believe these fun dead freakazoids
are here to party hardy Polly Pound Town
rounded the corner of Main Street first
on his ride the murderlizer in past life
had been a coffin but now with the aid
of two monster truck wheels on the back
and a pair of circular saw blades on the
front it was a vehicle ready to tear up
the streets literally Polly drove down
the road at a Breakneck Pace leaving a
trail of Sparks and black smog behind
him he was screaming something about
being King of the war world when the
vehicle exploded Underneath Him the
force of the boom flung Polly down the
length of the street he hit the window
of a local barber shop and shattered
through like a flushing missile for a
moment he lay on the tiles a leather pin
cushion of broken glass and wooden
shrapnel from the recently detonated
fertilizer but had no moment in this
whole insane ordeal did Paulie stop
laughing he got up noticed his neck was
twisted backward at an odd angle we told
you it was a Breakneck Pace but Polly
just grabbed that sucker and crunched it
back into place it'd take a little more
than a totaled spine to stop pawley
pound town after all the night's fun was
only just starting more tricked out
zombie roadsters were pouring into the
town from every angle hopped up on a
combination of tequila lighter fluid and
some stuff we can't even mention if we
want to keep monetization on this video
Steely Dan was roaring into the
Build-A-Bear workshop on a modified
toilet with all crushing caterpillar
tracks once he'd busted through the
facade he dismounted his porcelain
throne and began incinerating walls of
teddy bears with a custom flamethrower
powered by a tube going into his stomach
cavity once he was done burning ninety
percent of the Bears in the store he
used the remaining unsullied parts to
make a grungy looking bear in his own
likeness he strapped it to the front of
his terrifying mobile toilet and then
burnt that too just for the fun of it
bareback Boris was making a beeline for
the ice cream parlor riding what would
look like a bowl to the untrained eye it
was actually a taxidermied pole gutted
and fitted with a nightmarish
configuration of motorcycle parts that
would function better together as a
method of execution than a workable
vehicle but that's just how the
exploding zombie Gearheads like it Boris
pulled the handbrake which was made out
of some old bones he duck up once and
ground the bull cycle to a screeching
halt in front of the Parlor he climbed
off and kicked in the door before
running in to cause some chaos Boris The
Animal that he was grabbed handfuls of
gelato and shove them into his mouth
before turning and spitting them at the
wall he pulled out a bottle of 90 vodka
and took a long Swig before taking a
court summons out of his jacket and
shoving it into the bottle he lit the
top of the litigious fuse with his
lighter which was shaped like a knife
and made a Molotov cocktail moments
later the whole store was in Flames
Boris stepped out of the burning ice
cream parlor on fire but utterly unfazed
he pulled out no less than four cigars
and lit them on his own burning skin
before smoking each one in a single pole
if his lungs didn't already look like
black and lumps of decaying coal they
would have been screaming at him but
right now the only person screaming was
Gene Simmons of the band KISS as some of
boris's fellow writers rampaged through
the streets past him Unholy blaring from
their radios at ear exploding volumes
the exploding zombie Gearheads didn't
throw out of town ragers like this off
often but when they did they always
tried to make it one for the history
books and before you start worrying
about the safety of the citizens of
lethargy Valley Arizona you should know
that the zombie Gearheads never hurt
anybody well never hurt anybody on
purpose that is if a piece of stray
shrapnel from an exploding Camaro
reshaped with scrap metal to look like a
giant fist spraying fire from its
Knuckles happens to take out somebody's
eye well that can't really be seen as
anybody's fault can it especially when
you don't have eyes anymore the closest
thing to the brains of this operation
which for these guys really isn't saying
much was a free thinking free-spirited
free liquored individual known as Joey
nuts the whole gang had probably about
40 brain cells between them but at least
five of those cells belonged to Joey
while many of his rotting buddies were
goofing off and causing Mayhem across
town Joey was already acting on the real
reason everybody was here getting new
parts for their sick is all hell car
mods sure as mechanics they couldn't
produce actually workable Vehicles worth
a damn but at the end of the day isn't a
vehicle looking awesome much more
important than boring old functionality
if you think otherwise you're probably
just a square but we digress back to
Joey
um
nuts Joey and a crew of his boys
including Dirty Mike scuzzy Steve and
generally unclean Gary rolled up to one
of the local auto body shops and bashed
the door down with their vehicle which
by the way was a modified SUV modified
with bulldozer parts and a makeshift
Cannon it was a powerful if structurally
unsound motorized Siege weapon Joey and
the boys jumped off the vehicle and
stormed into the building wielding pipe
wrenches with nails and fishing hooks
welded onto them a confused mechanic was
quaking in this boot says the gaggle of
zombie Gearheads approached him Joey
stood at the front swinging his pipe
wrench around with menacing Randomness
he was chewing 12 toothpicks making him
look extra tough the mechanic with a
quiet trembling voice told Joey and the
boys that they needed to leave they
weren't supposed to be back here they
needed to leave and come back during
opening hours it was the most polite
telling off he could possibly muster the
exploding zombie Gearheads just laughed
once they were done cackling Joey lifted
up his pipe wrench and pointed it at the
terrified mechanic's face Joey cleared
his tobacco and gasoline burn throat and
said listen you stupid Grease Monkey I'm
only gonna say this once so open your
ear holes real wide and listen up okay
you're gonna pack up your crap and leave
so me and my boys can loot this place to
a heart's content and beef up our sick
ass rides and if you don't leave
you're gonna be holding this your pipe
wrench for me in your prison pocket you
get me the mechanic definitely got him
he didn't waste a moment in hightailing
it out of the store while Joey and the
boys pulled a classic Smash and grab on
his Wares they stole everything from
Whole cars to wrenches and lug nuts
across town the exploding zombie
Gearheads were doing the exact same
thing stealing or stripping every
vehicle in sight and cannibalizing the
parts for their own righteous whips town
by town vehicle by vehicle explosion by
explosion they'd one day figure this
whole mechanic deal out with the Knights
revelry finally concluded it was time to
return home and get to work on the next
set of rides this Legion of awesome
unkillable morons piled back into their
stylish death traps and rode off into
the Misty Dawn leaving hundreds of
thousands of dollars in property damage
behind them but not a single death as
hyper-destructive anomalies go they're
honestly pretty benevolent or at least
too self-centered to be truly malevolent
they tore up the desert on their way
back to the real
scp-3885 vulture Gulch the home of the
exploding zombie Gearheads it's a desert
Shanty Town that's officially been
abandoned since July 9 1973 due to high
volumes of dangerous Radeon gas being
emitted from the uranium deposits in a
nearby mine but these intense joyriding
mutants hardly mind a little bit of
radiation in their sweet pad be it ever
so Radioactive there's no place like
home right some of the vehicles even
exploded on the way back to the place
but the boys didn't mind the Flaming
explosion survivors just crawled out of
the fire and hopped onto the rides of
their closest buddies all in all
everyone in attendance had a damn good
time that night they'd spend the rest of
the early morning setting rocks on fire
for fun and chewing on ignited fireworks
that's the kind of Brain Trust we're
dealing with here when the foundation
eventually contained them in vulture
Gulch the Gearheads didn't even put up a
fuss as long as the foundation kept
supplying them with three decommissioned
Vehicles every month it's a pretty sweet
deal a crazed car Lover's Paradise where
as long as you keep it within the walls
anything goes baby but there is one
strange little detail a question that
remains unanswered drones sent in by the
foundation to spawn the residents of
vulture Gulch have picked up one strange
recurring theme in their chatter
mentions of an individual known only as
the boss paying them a visit and we can
only assume they don't mean Bruce
Springsteen the only Clues we have are
that the Gearheads believe this boss
created them and put them here on this
Earth to be totally rad the other clue
is a seemingly pervasive belief that
someday soon the boss will return who do
you think the boss of the exploding
zombie Gearheads truly is let us know
down in the comments man it's even
better on the 15th read oh hello I
didn't see you there dear viewers of SCP
explained I'm on break between
supervising a cpu-682 termination
attempts and inspecting the mops we use
on scp-173's leavings so I decided to do
what all the cool people are doing in
their spare time right now rereading
chainsaw man the hit manga by Japanese
author and artist tatsuki Fujimoto for
the uninitiated it's the story of denji
a poor young man from Japan who makes
his living hunting Devils dangerous
creature features that are embodiments
of Mankind's greatest fears but when
that living leads to him dying at the
hands of a gang of zombie Yakuza believe
me it makes sense in context he bonds
with the legendary chainsaw devil and is
reborn as chainsaw man an unconventional
superhero who chainsaws first and asks
questions later naturally I was eager to
see how one of our own bloodthirsty
Killers would fare against denji's
chainsaws of Fury so I selected the most
violent battle-hardened and Carnage
hungry anomaly out there
scp-076-2 The Immortal Warrior known as
Abel the two of them have a surprising
amount of things in common both are
effectively Immortal and can revive
after sustaining massive physical
injuries both absolutely love to fight
with their array of deadly weapons and
anomalous strength both have been part
of experimental operations groups with
denji being a member of Japan's Public
Safety devil Hunters division IV and
able being an ex-member of the SCP
foundation's disastrous Pandora's Box
mobile task force most of which he later
massacred out of boredom you can
probably see why these two really did
feel like the perfect match-up so after
forcing the trustee anomatron 6000 to
read every currently available volume of
Chainsaw man and compute years of Abel's
gruesome battle data I've set up the
perfect simulation for your viewing
pleasure and hey fellow fans of the
manga isn't it horrifying that even we
beat mappa to the punch of animating
this thing
oh God that joke will age poorly if that
anime comes up before this anyway let's
crank this machine into action and let
her rep Japan
1997. everything is roasting in the July
heat Men In Black Harrison Ford's Air
Force One and Air Bud are hitting
theaters for the first time everything
is right with the world that's why over
in the headquarters of the public safety
hunting Department denji our chainsaw
loving hero is being praised by his kind
boss and Mentor figure makima a lovable
supportive woman who will never do
anything wrong she even loves dogs how
could a person who loves dogs ever be
evil that very morning denji and his
chainsaw man form managed to defeat the
accidentally making a mistake on your
tax forms and now you're going to prison
devil who had been terrorizing downtown
Tokyo it was a challenging battle but in
the end he'd managed to turn the tables
and defeat the creature by setting it on
fire needless to say makima was
extremely pleased with dengie's work
here but now she had considerably more
Graver news to impart she'd gotten word
from an Envoy of another organization
that hunts down dangerous and anomalous
creatures the SCP Foundation that an
extremely lethal entity had breached
their containment and was now somewhere
in Japan the entertain question was not
a devil and thereby would be working on
a different rule set makima opened a
file fax Tour by the foundation yes
remember this is set in 1997 and gave
denji The crucial Lowdown several hours
ago the entity known as Abel had
resurrected from his huge black
sarcophagus in the underwater chamber of
the classified facility containment area
25b after waking up Abel had slaughtered
his way through the entire base killing
every SCP Foundation operative in his
path and then swimming out into the
Pacific Ocean sometime after that he
infiltrated a Japanese cargo ship and
murdered all the workers on board before
steering the ship back towards the Land
of the Rising Sun where he hoped to
claim even more victims makima told
denji that it would fall to him and his
associates to stop this able With a
Little Help from the SCP foundation's
intelligence but be warned Abel is an
incredible combatant with extreme
physical strength and durability as well
as surprising tactical intelligence it
wouldn't be an easy fight but makina
promised that if denji won she'd hug him
and go to a nearby karaoke bar with him
denji replied consider him dead already
miss makima meanwhile Abel was walking
through the slums of Tokyo marveling at
the neon signs for bars and clubs his
journey to Japan hadn't been an accident
Abel had been to Japan once before in
the year
1605. he'd faced the legendary Japanese
philosopher and swordsman miado Musashi
considered by many to be one of the
greatest warriors in human history Abel
had dueled Musashi who famously wielded
two katanas at once in the hills of the
harima province where after a tense
battle Musashi cut him down Abel would
not resurrect again during Musashi's
lifetime but the battle gave him a deep
and abiding respect for the legendary
Warrior Abel knew that if the
opportunity ever rose again he returned
to Japan in hopes of experiencing such a
brilliant battle yet again but the
industrial and technological boom had
changed so much it was no longer the
quiet and pastoral Japan he'd
experienced but a booming epicenter of
trade and commerce he found it all
strange and perplexing suddenly he found
himself surrounded by a group of
Japanese street thugs many of them
wielding switchblades they laughed at
his strange outfit which to them looked
like an old worn bed sheet one of the
smarter members of the group had already
decided to go home when the others made
up their mind to mug Abel the Warrior's
extensive tattoos made him look like a
middle eastern Yakuza Dawn the rest
however were happy to take their chances
with him emptier pockets of that goofy
toga even has pockets the leader said
holding up his switchblade unless you
want to get cut Abel just smirked and
Drew a pair of long obsidian daggers in
the following Moment The Alley was
filled with screams then was silent yet
again Abel walked on breathing a sigh of
disappointment at how incredibly
mediocre this first fight had been his
blade stripping with fresh blood Musashi
is rolling in his grave Abel thought to
himself meanwhile across town denji and
the rest of division four were
mobilizing it was him the serious sword
Wheeling Aki and the adorable
pathologically lying blood-phiend power
they'd been told over the phone by a man
named Dr bright that Abel would be
relatively easy to track down he's not
known for his subtlety all you need to
do is follow the trail of Carnage he
causes wherever he goes from the way he
talks about him it seems almost as
though Dr bright Bears a personal grudge
against Abel how strange power didn't
seem intimidated she proudly proclaimed
I don't think this battle will be
difficult at all in fact I faced this
Abel before and defeated him handily Aki
sighed and asked one when did this
happen last Tuesday of course she
replied power had only heard about Abel
this morning but denji and Aki have
learned better than to dispute her at
this point suddenly a large television
screen that had been previously relaying
an ad for a cutting-edge stereo system
cut to an emergency news report there
had been a horrific incident in downtown
Tokyo where a bar had been attacked and
most of its patrons murdered by a
deranged tattooed man carrying a pair of
huge swords Aki immediately recognized
this place the bar was Yakuza owned if
this able was on the hunt for worthy
opponents it makes all the sense in the
world that Japan's iconic crime
syndicates would be his first Target
denji Aki and power knew exactly where
they needed to go over at the bar Abel
was having a whale of a Time innocent
patrons were running and screaming while
the Yakuza engaged in an all-out war
with a terrifying inhuman Warrior
several firm had already been cut down
two Yakuza soldiers behind the bar were
reloading illegal Uzis and preparing to
return fire both were sweating terrified
by the sudden random attack when they'd
shot him before he'd managed to dodge
most of the bullets and expertly blocked
the rest with his swords who the hell
had sent this monster was he with the
Triads the Russian mob or some devil
summoned by the Japanese government to
crack down on them whatever the case he
seemed almost impossible to kill the two
men stood back up and opened fire Abel
held his two swords and spun like a
propeller blocking all the bullets
almost effortlessly he then produced
another dagger seemingly from thin air
and threw it directly into the heart of
one of the two remaining Yakuza behind
the bar he dropped to the ground dead
instantly leaving only his friend alive
in a bar full of corpses that's when
Abel noticed a decorative katana behind
the bar he smiled and ordered the
surviving Yakuza Soldier to pick up the
sword and give him a real fight the
hapless monster realized in that moment
that this guy was truly crazy whoever he
was but what choice did he have now with
tear in his heart the last surviving
Yakuza grabbed the katana and uncheathed
it good Abel said his voice deep in
menacing now come fight me let's see if
you last a few seconds longer than your
worthless friends shall we he did not
the second the Yakuza ran towards Abel
and the ancient swordsman swiped at him
with one of his blades cutting through
the katana and the opponent holding it a
puny gangster never stood a chance
against a deadly Immortal Warrior and
Abel was Furious the last time he was
here he faced a truly expert killer who
even managed to end Abel's life in a
single combat and now he was slaying
insects in a karaoke bar pathetic
suddenly his ears pricked up he turned
to see a red ax flying at his head at
incredible speed
for this superhuman reflexes he managed
to dodge just in time but the ACT still
cleaved off a chunk of his hair as it
passed Abel could see the one who threw
it standing at the entrance to the bar
it was the blood fiend power that made
the ax out of her own blood standing
next to her were denji and Aki denji
wielding an axanaki stoically observing
damn Miss makima promised we do karaoke
at this bar if I beat you Dungy said
you're going down for this Abel smiled
and pulled out another pair of blades
finally he roared Warriors who fight the
old-fashioned way I feared the years had
stolen you all from me power step
forward producing another Blood Ax from
nowhere she yelled tremble in fear Abel
tis I your arch nemesis the mighty power
Abel had literally never seen her before
and as thousands of years of life but he
appreciated that these warriors were at
least able to match his level of drama
as far as he was concerned the fight was
on but even Abel didn't know the level
of fighting he was getting in for here
as he charged forward the trio split
immediately surrounding him good tactics
Abel thought to himself already this was
promising Aki who had remained quiet up
to this point attacked first he drew a
tatano knife from his suit jacket and
slashed at Abel with impressive speed
but unlike three of the other combatants
in this situation Aki was only human
which gave him a serious disadvantage
Abel decided it would be best to put him
out of commission first with a quick and
brutal kick to the chest Aki was thrown
against the wall with the majority of
his ribs broken revved up by his own
bloodlust Abel turned to dengian power
and grin like a maniac this was already
the most fun he'd had in a long time who
are these people doesn't matter he
thought they'll be dead soon anyway
while Abel was still locked in thought
power pulled out a comically large
Hammer made out of her own blood and
brought it down towards Abel he was
surprised by the sudden attack did this
girl have the same weapon producing
Powers as him this just keeps getting
more interesting
power screamed as the hammer came down
you have once again been defeated by the
mighty power again just to clarify these
two had never met each other but it was
already too late Abel punched upwards
his clenched fist colliding with the
hammer he hit it with such terrifying
force that powers blood Hammer shattered
against his knuckles in that same
instant Abel noticed denji running at
him with an ax from behind Abel produced
another obsidian dagger and threw it
into denji's forehead dropping him to
the ground immediately pathetic power
tried to produce another weapon but she
used up too much blood already before
she had a chance to make anything
substantial Abel sprung forwards with
terrifying speed trying to land a
killing blow but even weakened power was
freakishly fast she was able to dodge
his blow and kick him in the ribs
momentarily stunning him of course she
took the time to gloat putting her hands
on her hips and laughing victoriously
need a second to catch your breath Abel
it to be expected
none can keep up with me she
grandulously announced perhaps you
should just give up and agree to become
my servant
I might even teach you a thing or two
about fighting suddenly Abel was
standing right in front of her squeezing
her throat with his iron grip he smiled
flashing teeth and said if you want to
kill kill don't talk with a surprisingly
minimal amount of strength he squeezed
and heard a crunch from power's neck he
dropped her limp body to the ground
lucky for power Abel wasn't aware that a
fiend-like power can survive an injury
like this as long as she's fed some more
blood instead he just sighed in
disappointment is that all you weaklings
have to offer he bellowed Aki barely
conscious after being kicked against the
wall remain just conscious enough to
activate his contract with a Powerful
Beast known as the fox devil he twists
his hands into a strange gesture and
Whispers the word Kong before falling
unconscious but that's still enough
suddenly a gigantic demonic Fox claw
burst through the wall of the bar
spraying dust and Rubble everywhere Abel
was definitely not expecting that he
dodged several times as the claw swiped
for him often barely missing him for its
last Strike It lunged Forward and raked
four claw marks across his chest Abel
was shocked by the sudden pain it felt
fantastic he pulled a long obsidian
spear out of one of his pocket
dimensions and forced it down through
the fox Devil's paw and into the ground
pinning it in place after a moment of
thrashing the claw dissipated into smoke
lending Abel another Victory though even
he would admit this was a more exciting
fight than the other ones had been was
that it had he gained total Victory once
more just like he so often did these
days he was about to take pity on
himself when denji rose up behind him
how about a rematch then she asked Abel
grinned he liked this kid challenged me
child Abel said well since you asked
dingy smirked denji reached into his
shirt and grabbed the ripcord emerging
from his chest it was time to go into
overdrive on this thing he gave it a
mighty yank and like the Rev of a
chainsaw the madness began denji
transformed giant blades emerging from
his arms and his head transformed into a
toothy saw blade nightmare he gave a
mechanical Roar that spewed smoke this
wasn't just Dungey anymore this was
chainsaw man now this Abel thought
feeling his adrenaline spike is more
like it following dungey's lead Abel
reached into one of his pocket
dimensions and pulled out one of his
favorite weapons one he'd only
previously used against the mighty hard
to destroy reptile
scp-682 the chainsaw Claymore a huge
two-handed sword with the eternally
twisting shredding teeth of a chainsaw
ever circulating around it it was time
for chainsaw vs chainsaw what the hell
are you waiting for chainsaw man Roar
are we gonna stand around all day or are
we gonna fight Abel couldn't have said
it better himself the two charged at one
another at lightning speeds chainsaw
clashing against chain sword the sheer
force of the contact was enough to send
a shock wave blasting through the bar it
rapidly became a power struggle each of
them trying hard to force their
chainsaws out of the stalemate realizing
that this time he perhaps couldn't win
with raw strength able back flipped away
to reassess his options but chainsaw man
had no intention of giving Abel time to
think about it he darted towards Abel
with the weight and momentum of a
runaway freight train if Abel hadn't
raised his Claymore to Perry it would
have been shredded to Pieces by the
devil's saws in an instant instead the
two of them rocketed out of the nearby
wall in a Cascade of debris causing
everyone on the outside Street to run
for their lives the two quickly stood
from the stumble the two quickly stood
up catching their breath impressive Abel
said you're much better than the others
instead of replying denji briefly
retracted his arm chainsaws and grabbed
a nearby parked car throwing it directly
at Abel Abel reacted quickly leaving the
car in half with his clay more charging
for chainsaw man again just before Abel
could land a lethal strike chainsaw man
deployed his chainsaws again blocking
the blow Abel sped around him trying to
strike again and again but chainsaw man
blocked every strike with stunning
efficacy Abel was astonished few had
ever been able to go Toe to Toe with him
like this before he could feel his heart
pounding gloriously in his chest he
would give denji A Warrior's death with
a furious yell Abel brought down the
chainsaw Claymore for a devastating
vertical strike but chainsaw man was
ready he arranged his arm chainsaws in a
cross formation like a giant pair of
scissors and caught Abel's chain sword
between them chainsaw man pulled his
arms in opposite directions slicing
Abel's mighty sword in half the immortal
swordsman skidded backwards to avoid the
Fallout producing two smaller blades
immediately this chainsaw man just kept
exceeding expectations didn't he Abel
would need to change tactics if he
wanted to win this one chainsaw man was
impressed by the speed and tenacity of
his Foe for someone who apparently
wasn't even a devil Abel sure packed a
hell of a punch did he ever run out of
those damned weapons though attempting
to answer chainsaw man's question for
him Abel began running around his flank
rapidly producing and throwing blades
and axes in a startling volley chainsaw
man was able to use his chainsaw arms
and face to block most of them but not
all of them several daggers and small
throwing axes splattered into the tender
flesh of Chainsaw Man's Chest Abel had
successfully wounded him and he wasn't
done feeling a little more confident now
Abel decided to take a different tactic
he produced a large spiked mace from
thin air and ran at chainsaw man while
the devil was still recovering from his
projectile attack with one brutal whack
he sent denji flying down the street
carving a rut into the concrete beneath
him but Abel wasn't done while chainsaw
man was still trying to recover Abel
leaped on to him and began beating him
into the ground with his mace the
strikes were so brutal they shook the
Earth and sent cracks across the
surrounding ground then Abel stopped he
realized for a moment that he was
letting his bloodlust get the better of
him this was dishonorable where would be
the fun in beating this boy to death
while he lay on the ground and depriving
himself of one of the greatest opponents
he's had in quite some time no that
would not do it all he'd give him one
more chance on your feet boy Abel said
you fight well get up and carry on I
won't let a beast as rare as you die
like a common dog rise and fight me and
Chainsaw man did as he was told Abel was
shocked to see the very ground shatter
underneath him as chainsaw man burst up
through it all his swords at the ready
the mace was thrown from Abel's hands as
chainsaw man launched up towards him all
metal teeth and fury luckily for Abel he
pulled out a battle ax just in time to
block the flurry of brutal strikes from
the patron saint of chainsaws now this
was a fight even Musashi would be proud
of yes Boy Yes Abel yelled this is true
combat chainsaw man replied with the
swing of his blades which Abel was
nearly able to dodge the two finally
landed back down on the ground and Abel
was fast enough to bury his battle ax
and Chainsaw man's shoulder before the
devil could return a blow to Abel the
anomalous swordsman pulled out a pair of
his favorite swords and locked chainsaw
man's arms in place chainsaw man was
undeniably incredibly powerful but it
looked like Abel's Superior experience
and tactics might save him this time
what the hell are you chainsaw man Lord
you've been a worthy opponent boy those
are feeling fine between Abel said I'll
remember you for this but before Abel
could execute a killing blow he felt a
blood red throwing ax stick into his
back Abel Winston Payne to see Power and
Aki about 30 feet behind him power was
propping Aki up he donated some of his
blood to bring her back to life and she
was just as delusionally cocky as ever
Abel was about to say something but he
already made a fatal mistake letting his
guard down before another word could
pass the cursed Warrior's lips one of
Chainsaw man's armed chainsaws passed
directly through his heart tearing it
apart with a navel's chest it was a
sudden and decisive killing blow
chainsaw man pulled his saw back out of
Abel's chest stained with the deadly
anomaly's blood Abel collapsed to the
ground wheezing and bleeding profusely
from the hole in his chest but strangely
as power Aki and Chainsaw man converged
around him they realized he was smiling
thank you Abel said and died yet again
with the battle won like an Incredible
Hulk made of metal chainsaw man
transformed back into denji the trio
stood around Abel's corpse deeply
confused as to what had just happened if
this was the kind of thing the SCP
Foundation normally dealt with they all
silently agree that perhaps it would be
better not to get in involved with them
in the future except power of course who
said you two should be thanking me for
defeating him
you both owe me drinks for this hundreds
of miles away in a black sarcophagus
deep underwater surrounded by
professional as CP Foundation divers
Abel's body once again returned who
knows how long he'd remained sleeping in
there but what we do know is that his
deathless sleep was suffused with the
sweet dreams knowing that this world
still held or the opponents and for Abel
that was everything now go check out
could scp-682 be contained in the back
rooms and scp-096 vs siren head for more
deranged out of universe crossovers from
the SCP Foundation